three-two-one Brian Greene ladies and
gentlemen how are you sir
good thank you how are you doing this
man my pleasure enjoyed your work for
many many many years so I really
appreciate you coming in well thank you
I appreciate that
like I was telling you I just started
your new book and how's it going it's
going well it's hasn't confusing [ __ ]
out of me yet but I know it's coming it
will be coming no doubt yeah with all
your work so the beginning of time the
beginning of the universe - the end
that's essentially what you're
summarizing yeah that's the that's the
backdrop to the entire narrative of the
book I I basically want the reader to
get a feel for the whole thing how it
started how things like you and me rise
up how consciousness emerges issues a
free will and whether we have it and
then on to the future what's going to
happen to us and the world and the
universe as time elapses to the far far
future it's uh I'm just getting to the
part where you're talking about how
entropy and evolution sort of commingle
to create life and when you think of
entropy a lot of people think of
something dissolving into chaos yeah
exactly but that's not necessarily the
case it's only part of the story I mean
entropy kind of gets a bad rap right
it's the thing that you want to avoid
but somehow the laws of physics don't
allow you to avoid it it's this
disintegration it's this decay it's this
drive toward disorder and that's kind of
true but the reality of the situation is
more subtle because overall entropy
needs to go up but that doesn't mean
there can't be little pockets of order
that form along the way and in fact the
universe is incredibly clever stars the
ubiquitous feature of the heavens they
are pockets of order that naturally form
but as they form they increase the
entropy in the surroundings so the net
entropy goes up even though this
beautiful orderly bright object in the
sky appears and it's only because of the
appearance of stars that the universe is
an interesting place without stars the
particles of the universe would just
disperse the universe would get bigger
and bigger colder and colder
and that would be it there wouldn't be
any structure in the universe if it
wasn't for the force of gravity stars
themselves just the fact that they exist
is very strange that you have this thing
and ours is fairly small right it's a
million times larger than Earth yeah and
it's going to burn for billions of years
and it's just hovering there yeah and it
creates all the life yeah literally is
responsible for all the life yeah and
when they supernova that creates the
actual ingredients for life which is
even more strange like you can't have
biological carbon-based life if it's not
for a star exploding yeah I mean we
often in a poetic way said that we are
made of star stuff
yeah that's Carl Sagan but you can also
say that we are are made of you know
nuclear refuse right we heard the news
right us yeah that that the death throes
of a star puts out into the universe and
it rains down on planets and at least on
one such planet that stuff comes
together and yields life so it is a
cycle I mean I don't want to sound like
The Lion King here but you know it
that's really what it is
well what I'm so interested in about in
getting into your book is the fact that
you are sort of detailing all these
steps that that have to take place in
order for all this life in order for
this universe to be what it is and then
where it's going to go yeah yeah exactly
and the remarkable thing and sort of
them the main point that some level is
that look we're special entities we can
think we can reflect we have emotions
but ultimately you and I and everybody
else were just bags of particles that
are governed by physical law and so
there's this continuity between the
stuff of the world the inanimate stuff
of the world the inanimate stuff of the
heavens and us we all come from the same
fundamental ingredients in the same
fundamental laws now some people find
that that gives them I don't know a
sense of desperation a sense we're not
special a sense that somehow the
universe is pointless or meaningless but
you know my view on this is it's
spectacular that we're made of the same
stuff that makes up this bottle of water
or any of the wonderful little statues
you have on this desk because that means
that how remarkable that collections of
particles can do what we do mm-hmm and I
think that's really the way of looking
at the continuity we don't need to be
endowed with some special quality by
some external entity you don't need that
particles can do miraculous things and
that is the message that I think you can
draw from a more complete understanding
of where we came from and where we're
going that the fear of death and the
attitude of the finite life being
insignificant that like what is the
point this sort of existential angst
that many of us struggle with right yeah
right that's something that you touch
upon really early on that this this
thing that makes us unique is that we
know that we're gonna die yeah yeah that
that to me is the vital distinguishing
feature of our species you know we can
reflect on the past we can think about
the future and recognize that we're not
going to be here in the future these for
some period of time and it's um it's an
idea and it's powerful motivating
influences one that has been explored
throughout the ages Auto ronk was one of
the early disciples of Freud who
ultimately broke with Freud developed
this thesis that our awareness of our
own mortality is one of the driving
factors in what we do and then when I
was on and it was in my 20s or 30s I
read a book by a guy named Ernest Becker
called denial of death I'm have you ever
heard of this book it was it was big in
the 70s and one actually the Pulitzer
Prize in the 70s and it's a wonderful
distillation of this way of thinking
about why we humans do what we do and in
many ways in my own book the one was
coming out actually today until the end
of time it's um it's extending this
notion that Becker developed in denial
of death but now seeing it in a
cosmological setting because it's not
just we that are going to die it's every
structure in the universe
is going to disintegrate in time our our
best theories suggest to us that even
protons the very heart of matter their
quantum processes that in the far future
will ensure that every proton
disintegrates falls apart into its
constituent particles and at that point
there's no complex matter around at all
what are the would timeline are we
talking well pretty pretty big long
timeline in fact I'd like to use a
metaphor to try to give you a feel for
the times involved I like to use the
Empire State Building and imagine that
every floor of the Empire State Building
represents a duration 10 times that of
the previous floor so like on the ground
floor it's like one year first floor 10
year second floor 100 and so forth so
you're going exponentially far in time
as you climb up the Empire State
Building and in that scheme of things
everything from the Big Bang until today
you're about at the 10th floor 10 to the
10 years 10 billion years and as you go
forward you are looking at things very
far in the future and to answer your
question we think and i underscore think
because we're now at the speculative end
of our theoretical ideas protons will
decay roughly and say by the 38th floor
so 10 to the 38th years into the future
so we can relax for a little bit you can
relax for a little bit but here's here's
the thing the amazing thing obviously is
it sounds trite but time is relative
right so any duration that seems long
it's only long by comparison to another
duration and on say the scale of the
entire empire state building up to say
ten to the hundred years into the future
which is what the peak would represent
10 to the 38 years is like less than a
blink of an eye I mean it's nothing on
those scales so you sort of have to be
careful whether you're your intuition if
you're willing to entertain the kind of
fantastically long time scales that you
necessarily need to if you're going to
think about the very far future is there
speculation as to what happens when
protons do cease to exist yeah
we anticipate that all complex structure
will fall apart so if there any stars
left over we believe that by the 14th
floor
most stars will have use up their
nuclear fuel there will be dark embers
just sort of you know smoky out there in
the cosmos but if they're still hovering
around by the 38th floor they will all
just dissipate into their particular
ingredients so it's hard to imagine past
safe floor 38 that there's gonna be any
life for any mind or any complex
astronomical structures out there in the
universe so the window within which the
universe as we know it exists is kind of
small
when you think about it in terms of the
entire cosmic timeline so impossible to
understand the actual span of it because
it is so long but yet so small like yeah
in the human mind yeah it's very hard to
hold these durations yeah in mind I mean
I don't I don't feel like I've been
thinking about this stuff for a long
time I don't feel like I have an
intuition for the durations that we are
talking about in fact the Empire State
Building that little analogy helps me to
sort of give some relative sense of when
things of interest will happen the
universe but you know we're good at
understanding days weeks months years
the times of you know conventional
experience we have no basis for
understanding the universe over these
scales that we've never experienced you
know and that's true not only for time
it's also for a space right I mean we
have very good intuition about everyday
phenomena I mean if I have to take this
bottle of water I throw it at you you'd
catch it you know where to put your hand
you wouldn't have to calculate it's
Newtonian trajectory to figure out where
the water is going but if I was to do
the same thing with electrons you don't
have a neither do I a quantum intuition
about the wave functions and the
probabilities that govern how a particle
like an electron behaves and that's
simply because we were unfortunately or
fortunately born as big creatures
relative to the scales of quantum
mechanics and because of that our
intuition was never under any
evolutionary pressure to understand how
electrons behave in fact I like to say
those of our forebears wandering around
the African savanna who started to think
about electrons in quantum mechanics
they got eaten right there the
whose genes didn't propagate onward and
therefore those of us who are the
beneficiaries of the survival of our
ancestors were good at understanding
Newtonian physics but we're not good at
understanding anything else about the
deep reality of the world do you
anticipate that someday in the future
whatever is next after human beings will
be able to understand these concepts
because if you stop and think about what
human is we've only really been this for
X amount a hundred thousand years that's
right and it's a it's a good question
and it's a tough one
I'd like to imagine that as we get ever
better at creating virtual worlds
virtual reality or whatever augmented
reality whatever version of that kind of
technology takes over in the far future
we might be able to experience these
distinct realms in such a powerful way
that our innate intuition may begin to
shift to change so that we grasp the
quantum realm the way we grasp Newtonian
physics I can at least imagine that as a
possibility what it would take to
actually get there and whether our
species will ever last long enough to
actually have that kind of an impact on
our intuition I don't know but it's all
about experience and survival we have
been programmed by evolution not to
understand the true nature of the world
we've been programmed by evolution to
survive and those are two radically
different propositions because you don't
need to know the true nature of reality
to survive it's a distinct attribute and
one that is not necessarily one that has
any survival value to understand black
holes or the Big Bang or general
relativity or quantum mechanics or
entropy or thermodynamics these
qualities we develop as we go forward
and try to understand the world go
beyond mere survival and figure out
things that excite us but it's not
something which obviously has any
survival value may someday MA
what's interesting is also how
relatively recently people have been
pondering these ideas
in a sort of a quantifiable way we can
write things down and sort of express it
with other scientists and try to figure
out who's right and who's wrong in terms
of these calculations but human beings I
mean what when did we really start
pondering the the scope of the universe
where did that pretty recently I mean if
you uh if you think about the beginnings
of modern physics you know you can start
with Galileo you can start with Newton
but many of them were talking on the
order of hundreds of years and the
amazing thing in hundreds of years we've
gone from a complete lack of
understanding about how anything in the
world actually works to the development
of Newton's equations where you can make
fantastically accurate predictions about
solar eclipses or lunar eclipses or
motions of the planets and so on and
then you know a couple hundred years
after that we migrate from that
understanding which is basically an
encapsulation of the patterns that we
can all discern with the naked eye we
develop a whole new body of physical law
called quantum mechanics which is so
completely counterintuitive which
describes the world in terms of
qualities that we don't ever see with
the naked eye but nevertheless we can
use the math to make predictions and the
predictions are borne out by experiment
and that progression only took say a
couple hundred years and that's where
we've gotten so it's kind of spectacular
that you know we beings who are just
coming of age here in the Milky Way
galaxy can sit down with a piece of
paper in a calculation a pencil and we
can figure out magnetic properties with
particles like electrons to ten decimal
places that's shocking
I mean it's stunning and it's something
that I think all of us should be very
proud of that our species has been able
to accomplish that somehow or another I
don't think I'm responsible feel proud
yeah I don't feel like any of my people
are involved you've you've contributed
your part you know it really is a
collective effort and that's the beauty
of science in the end of the day it's
not that most scientists are ever
going to be remembered you stop someone
in the street and ask them to name a
scientist yeah they may say hawking they
may say Einstein that's kind of it I
think for most people and I don't think
that's a bad thing per se because it's
not about the personalities or the
people that have pushed the frontiers of
understanding it's the fact that we've
got this body of insight that continues
to grow and continues to allow us to
manipulate and understand the natural
world and I think that's really what
it's all about don't you think that
there are some personalities like
yourself like fine men like I mean Neil
deGrasse Tyson that because of their
personality because they're sort of
they're charismatic people it actually
makes more people intrigued about these
possibilities and makes more people
attracted to the ideas yeah no doubt and
and I think that's a that's a vital
point because without that impetus from
outside the traditional educational
system I don't think we would have the
kind of interest in science that I can
feel growing you know in the world
around us I mean the unfortunate thing
in the educational system is that we
teach toward examination we teach toward
assessment and if you want to figure out
how to flatten a kids interest in these
ideas just teach them stuff and tell
them you're going to be tested on this
on Tuesday you're gonna have to spit
that you know everything that you've
learned so I find it kind of
heartbreaking the way in which so much
intrinsic interest in these ideas you
can see it a five or six year old right
I mean I like to say we begin as little
scientists we're exploring the world but
trying to figure things out and then we
go into the educational system and it's
not by by malice it's just by the nature
of how we teach in the in the current
you know approach to educational
philosophy that so many kids wind up
seeing these ideas is a burden hmm so
god I want to have to spend time
learning about parts of the cell or how
to balance reactions I see with my own
kids
I've got 15 year old son at 12 year old
daughter and all they are motivated by
is next Wednesday's quiz and I'm like
hey these ideas they're they're kind of
exciting they're kind of wonderful
at debt debt I just want to know enough
so I can you know do well on the quiz
and once the quiz is over they just sort
of leave the ideas behind when do these
ideas become attractive to you well I
was I don't know not unusual for a
scientist but unusual I think in the in
the spectrum of kids in the world
because at five or six years old I was
just captivated by mathematics really
yeah five or six definitely yeah my dad
my dad was not an academic my dad was a
composer he was a vaudevillian he was a
he was a comedian you know he was in the
early days would go around the country
and with a harmonica group and a stage
show that that's what he did you know he
liked to say that he was an S PhD a
Seward Park high school dropout you know
so at tenth grade he just hit the road
but he loved scientific ideas so he
taught me the basics of arithmetic when
I was about five years old and then I
would ask him to set me problems and he
give me these 30 digit numbers by 30
digit numbers I'd write them out in big
construction paper and I'd spend the
weekend just calculating away on these
huge you know arithmetic Allah problems
of no interest to anybody on planet
Earth but to me the fact that you could
learn a little piece of math and then do
something that nobody had ever done
before
that was exciting to me as a kid and
that's really what got me going so you
chose the right path clearly yeah
personality whatever it is that well you
always wonder about that oh no if you
wonder you know I was wonder how can you
not what would have happened if X would
have transpired instead of Y in fact I
have to say when I when I graduated
college I had sort of a a period of I
don't know depression is too strong a
word for it but a period of what have I
done I went to college I could have
studied all the great ideas of the world
and all I did was get a technical
education where I could solve
Schrodinger's equation and solve
Einstein's equations and I felt like wow
have I just like squandered the greatest
educational opportunity that one could
have ever had because I was so
completely
focused on just trying to understand
physics and mathematics past that well I
was lucky I was given a second chance
III won a scholarship to go to England
to Oxford and in ostensibly it was to
study physics but when I got there I
realized that I was completely free to
do whatever I wanted to do at that point
and so I took a year to study literature
I went to the physics classes so I was
sort of showing up but I wasn't focused
on it at all and instead I was focused I
got a you know in England it's a
tutorial system so I got a tutor which
is somebody at the college that sets you
assignments and you write papers you
literally go in and you read your paper
out loud it's not something we just
turned it in and it gets graded so it's
a very personal experience you write
something and you're actually delivering
it to this individual that is going to
help you in your educational journey and
so that's what I did for a year and at
the end of that year I kind of said to
myself okay I've got it
I understand now what it would mean to
study these these other subjects and I
sort of felt like I'll be able to do
this on my own if I continue to be
excited about it and I went back to
physics with a vengeance and basically
in that second year completed my
doctorate in in that year and and moved
on from there so this time that you took
off this year when you didn't really
take it off but you change pace yeah how
beneficial was that for you do you think
it helped you sort of appreciate what
your original subject of interest was as
well yeah hugely so because you know
it's funny it's the flip side of
something I often encounter with people
that are interested in science but don't
know the math and they always say or
some say I'm never really gonna
understand this body of science because
I don't know the mathematics and I try
to convince them look at some level
that's true if you really want to do
research in the general theory of
relativity you've got to learn
differential geometry and all the tensor
calculus but if you are really
interested in the ideas you really can
grasp the ideas without the technical
background so I try to demystify
something that can see
impenetrable because you haven't entered
the field and I think the same thing
happened to me in Reverse for the more
humanistic explorations it had this aura
of of grandeur that I was unable to
penetrate because I'd never really
immersed myself in the ideas and by
spending a year in those ideas it didn't
diminish them in any way but I felt like
it brought it back down to earth as
another journey toward truth another
pathway toward inside and one that you
don't have to have a degree in you don't
have to know the ins and outs of the
academic version of that subject to
understand it and grasp it and and spend
some time thinking about it so do you
think that for people studying anything
particularly those studying Science and
Mathematics very rigid disciplines do
you think that they all could benefit
from sort of expanding their education
into philosophy or art or something that
that uses your mind in a different way
yeah um some some there are some people
in the in the physics and mathematics
community who are so intensely focused
that it would almost be a shame to pull
their attention away from the deep dive
that they're going to do for the rest of
their lives and the contributions that
they're going to make and have made er
are substantial and and exciting but for
I think for many others and certainly
for me I mean look I as most people do
but not all but I've learned early on
that I'm not gonna be in Albert Einstein
you know I can make contributions and I
have had contributions to fails like
string theory and in cosmology but
they're never gonna be at the level of
shattering our understanding of the
world things that people are gonna talk
about five hundred years from now that's
unlikely and I think for somebody like
that who's able to make contributions
but pulling away from the technical work
is not gonna
extract some vital insight into the
nature of the world that otherwise
wouldn't be discovered I think there is
great value in doing exactly what you're
saying because by broadening your
perspective on what the work you're
doing is actually revealing it's part of
the human quest for understanding and
seeing it as an isolated discipline
where it's all about the next equation
and the better unified theory or the
deeper understanding of the Big Bang
to see that as isolated from the human
quest for understanding I think
diminishes the work that we as
physicists actually do was that a part
of your initial ambition yeah well is
something that we have rocked the world
yeah well to go back to the the comment
that you made before about we being the
only species that knows that we're going
to die I think part of that instills in
many people and certainly I see it in my
own life even though at the time that I
was making various decisions I wasn't
literally thinking about these kinds of
issues of mortality but how do you deal
with that recognition of the
impermanence of your own life well I
think part of it is a symbolic kind of
immortality you create something that
will last you create something that'll
have such impact that it will stick
around for a long long period of time so
I think yes I mean part of my motivation
in doing physics was not merely to get
the next decimal place in this or that
physical quantity described in the
natural world it was to try to have some
kind of insight that would rock our
understanding of the world and have
reverberations that would echo out for
many many years to come that's
interesting
did that torture you somewhat I mean is
that something that would haunted you is
it in your head all the time not really
uh but an ultimate ambition ultimate
ambition yes for sure and you know look
I think when when you're doing any work
whatsoever the day to day the moment to
moment is a grind you know I don't know
how you find it in the work that you're
doing but if I'm working on a research
project
even if in principle the ideas are grand
and wonderful and bold the
moment-to-moment is calculating away
it's trying to figure out that equation
it's put in an equation on a computer I
mean it is not sexy it is not something
that has that glorious quality that you
might ultimately describe when you're
finished and you look back and you think
about the implications of your work the
moment-to-moment of almost anything that
you do is a grind so so I think that's
ultimately what is the driver of
whatever you're doing in your life the
moment-to-moment
but yeah there is certainly a part of me
that would have a desire a hope that the
work would reverberate in a powerful way
I think that's true for most physicists
that that notion that you can sort of
sit at a table and think and change the
way we understand reality the way
Einstein did the way Schrodinger did the
way Niels Bohr did but like what
percentage of people you have that
revelation yeah I think it's I think
it's pretty few and far between nobody
else is sort of just contributing
contributing and usually someone exactly
some light bulb goes off sort of
powerful new inside and you're like okay
everything has suddenly changed that's
so exciting though and it's what keeps
going it keeps you going you know to be
the person who has the light bulb yeah
but I tell my students you know and
especially young students who come and
are still trying to figure out what they
want to do if you're not satisfied with
just contributing if you're not
satisfied with being part of the journey
but not the person at the head of the
breakthroughs it's probably not the
field for you because it's so unlikely
because it's not just brainpower it's
thinking of the right questions it's
thinking of things in the right
orientation it's being at the right
place at the right time with the right
DNA that somehow is attuned to the
question that's being asked so it's not
even fully under your control it's not
sort of a matter of you know exercising
your mind
and and building up the muscles of the
brain in such a way that you are the
strongest person to contribute to this
in this idea it's it's luck its timing
it's being there when the questions
being asked and you happen to see the
way forward that's it's so interesting
to me that there's so many people
working on all this stuff and the
average person that doesn't contemplate
quantum physics or these equations we
have no idea it's going on
yeah and that this all this work that's
so critical to our understanding of what
the universe really is with it the very
fiber of the universe itself yeah all
this is going on and most people are
just sort of they're reaping the
residual benefits of it yeah but they're
just wandering around not knowing yeah
hugely so in fact there's a number
that's quoted that quantum mechanics is
responsible for something like 35
percent of the gross national product so
so it's like it's in a very concrete way
now the the problem of that number is I
recently looked it up to find the source
of it so I sort of went online and
checked it out and apparently I'm the
source of this number and I assure you
that I've not done a calculation that
really fully justifies this but roughly
speaking you know anything that has an
integrated circuit is the result a
beneficiary of quantum insights so we
use this stuff every moment of our
technological lives and yet as you say
for the most part most of us don't have
a deep understanding of the reality
that's responsible for the gadgetry that
the sign says has given rise to and it's
a strange quantum mechanics is an
utterly strange reality too strange yeah
I I've tried many many times to try to
understand right whether it's Sean
Carroll's books
yeah or yours or any anyone's yeah it's
just it doesn't get in right and again
it goes back to you know our brains just
weren't under pressure to thing quantum
mechanically but I assure you you give
me a couple hours I mean books are one
thing because it's a one-sided
conversation but you give me a couple
hours in a back and forth and I will
absolutely get you to
place where you appreciate and have a
sense of what these ideas really are
telling us about the nature of the world
here's the thing that I've always wanted
to ask someone like you what do you
think was happening before the Big Bang
yeah it's a it's a it's a deep question
and a subtle one and there's sort of two
ways that I'd like to think about that
question one is it could be that the Big
Bang was an interesting event but not
the first event in the totality of
reality it could have been the first
event that sparked the expansion of our
part of space but it could be that
there's a grander realm of space within
which we sit as a small part and that
grander realm may have been here for a
far longer period of time it may have
experienced its own big bang's may be a
collection of big bangs that may extend
infinitely far into the past so it could
be that the answer to the question of
what happened before the Big Bang is a
lot of other big bangs or a lot of other
quantum events that were taking place in
a larger landscape of reality then we
have direct access to however another
answer is that the very question may not
make as much sense as the words seem to
suggest we know how to parse that
sentence we know what it means to talk
about the moment before the Big Bang
because we know how to talk about the
moment before your birth or the moment
before the Civil War or the moment
before any event that happened the world
we fully understand the meaning of that
kind of sentence but it could be that
when it comes to the Big Bang the
sentence actually doesn't mean anything
it could be that the Big Bang was the
place where time itself started and
Hawking himself had a wonderful analogy
to get this across he said look I'll
dress it up a little bit imagine you're
walking on planet Earth in you pass by
someone you say hey can you point me in
the direction of North I want to walk in
the northward direction the point you
continue to walk you pass by somebody
else a hey which way is further north
and they point you in that direction but
when you get to the North Pole and talk
to somebody there and say hey how do I
go further north they look at you and
say whoa that question doesn't mean
anything because this is where north
begin
there's no notion of going further north
than the North Pole and it could be that
that spatial metaphor applies to time
talk about a billion years ago ten
billion years ago but if you go to 13.8
billion years ago the Big Bang that may
be where time started and you can't go
further back in time than the very
origin of time itself that freaks me out
yeah see that that's one that it gets in
your head you know what do you mean
beginning of time yeah
why would time have a beginning good and
it could be it could be the time is an
emergent quality of reality I give you
an analogy boy what I mean by that is we
all know what temperature means
intuitively something's hot you feel it
something is called you feel it your
body understands those concepts what
physics has done is it's gone deeper
into the concept of temperature and
revealed that it is nothing but the
average motion of the particles making
up the environment so if the molecules
are moving really quickly you've got a
hot environment if the molecules are
really moving slowly it's a cold
environment so temperature emerges from
the motion of particles so if you have
like one particle you can't really talk
about it being hot or cold because you
need a conglomerate you need an
agglomeration of particles to be able to
talk about their average motion and in
that sense temperature is this emergent
idea that rests upon more fundamental
ideas the molecules and atoms that make
up reality maybe that's true of time
maybe time as we know it is a property
that only makes sense in certain
environments when there's enough stuff
arranged in the right patterns but
fundamentally maybe there are atoms or
molecules of time which when not
arranged in the form that we are
familiar with don't yield time as we
know it time itself may be a quality of
the world that exists here in this
environment but doesn't even apply in
other environments that are configured
radically differently whoa that's a
heavy one yeah that's a heavy one what
also is a heavy one is what caused
Big Bang yeah why would something's
smaller than the head of a pin
yeah become everything that we see in
the cosmos yeah so there are ideas for
the answer to that question look all
this is tentative because it's very hard
to do measurements that go all the way
back to the beginning we have
astronomical observations that we need
to be sure are compatible with the
predictions of our theories and so forth
so so we as good scientists do what
needs to be done to try to test these
ideas but the idea that I think most
physicists are cosmologists buy into at
the moment is that gravity can have two
manifestations the usual form of gravity
that you and I know about is the
attractive version you drop something
toward the Earth and it moves downward
because the earth and the object pull on
each other that's the ordinary gravity
that we experience every day of our
lives
but Einstein's equations actually allow
gravity to also be repulsive
it can push outward as opposed to just
pulling inward and this is something
that we have never experienced because
the gravity created by a rocky object
like the earth is always the attractive
variety the gravity created by the Sun
again a compact object is always the
attractive variety but Einstein's math
shows that if you don't have a rocky
object that's isolated in space but
rather energy that is uniformly spread
through a region of space that that kind
of entity yields repulsive gravity why
is that important to your question if
the very early universe that little tiny
head of a pin that you're talking about
if it was filled with a uniform bath of
this energy we call it the in photon
field the name doesn't matter but if it
was filled with that energy it would
have been subject to repulsive gravity
what does repulsive gravity do pushes
everything apart causes everything to
rush outward so the bang of the Big Bang
may have been a spark of repulsive
gravity operating with a tiny region of
space that pushed everything apart when
this concept of repulsive gravity is
just theoretical we observed any sort of
element in the universe that
it is theoretical but it's at a level of
understanding that I think most
physicists would say causes it to
migrate into the camp of established
understanding of how gravity works so
number one Einstein's equations have now
been tested over and over again and a
whole variety of circumstances the
detection of gravitational waves just a
couple of years ago it's like the
crowning triumph of Einstein's math a
hundred years ago the math says there
should be ripples in the fabric of space
a hundred years later we finally detect
ripples in the fabric of space so we are
very comfortable with any prediction
that comes out of Einstein's mathematics
and right in the mathematics is the
prediction of what I was just describing
you've got uniform energy in a region
repulsive gravity the other thing is we
currently witness that the expansion of
the universe is speeding up not slowing
down since the 1920s everybody thought
that yes the universe is expanding but
it will slow down over time
why because gravity pulls things back
together you throw an Apple upward it
doesn't go up faster and faster it goes
up slower and slower because the Earth's
gravity pulls it back everybody thought
that would apply to the universe as a
whole it's expanding but expanding ever
slower the observations in 1998
culminated in 1998 which won the 2011
Nobel Prize showed that the distant
galaxies are moving away ever more
quickly the expansion of space is
speeding up over time it's accelerating
how do we explain that the best
explanation we currently have is
repulsive gravity we believe even today
the universe is suffused with a bath of
energy we call it dark energy we believe
it's uniformly going through space I
like to think of it almost like a as a
Turkish sauna it's like the steam
filling the sauna of this energy filling
space and that repulsive gravity we
believe is responsible for the
observations that the distant galaxies
are rushing away faster and faster over
time so it's circumstantial but the case
for repulsive gravity is quite strong
and what would have caused it to
coalesce caused
compress and initially why would all
that matter be in this tiny yeah less
than a pin sized yeah so I have no idea
and nobody else on planet Earth has any
real idea other but we do have theories
and one of the theories suggest that in
the very early universe it was a highly
chaotic environment very hot with all
the fields fluctuating widely up and
down and the idea would be that if you
wait long enough where it's hard to know
what weight means in this environment
but don't press me on my definition of
time back then just sort of intuitively
if you wait long enough on rare
occasions the energy will just happen to
flatten out in a region become uniform
and then that region explosively
inflates grows large so you know it's
imagine you're looking at a pot of
boiling water the surface is of course
widely undulating up and down but if you
wait long enough very long time since
you've never seen it and neither have I
there will be a little patch on the
surface of that boiling water that
flattens out why that only means that
the water molecules happen for an
instant to be moving in just the right
way to keep that little patch of water
from wildly bubbling it will happen it's
rare but if you wait long enough it will
occur similarly the widely undulating
fields in the early universe if you wait
long enough a patch will flatten out you
get the uniform energy plug it into
Einstein's equations that region
explosively inflates and I mean
explosively it can go from size that's
much less than an atomic diameter to
larger than the observable universe in
far less than a blink of an eye in 10 to
the minus 30 10 to minus 35 seconds
that's how powerful repulsive gravity
can be that is so baffling yeah so
before that before this happens you just
have in this theory you just have all of
this energy sort of randomly interacting
with other energy in the universe with
no physical objects yep
yep it could have been forever that
could and in fact that's the main point
there's nobody who is hanging around
looking at their watch saying good God
when is this BIGBANG gonna finally
happen you know so so you can have this
cosmological pre-show you can have it
last as long as you like the only thing
that you need to happen is that sooner
or later a region flattens out and then
the cosmological show begins and if
we're looking at this model of the
universe being this infinite universes
yet with different characteristics and
different qualities to them this could
be happening throughout infinity yeah
all over the place yeah and in fact this
so-called inflation at cosmology is the
technical name for the subject says that
it says that it's quite likely that this
explosive inflation of the region that
we currently inhabit it was just one of
many such events and therefore there are
other far-flung regions throughout this
larger cosmological landscape where
things have also inflated but the
details can be different the physical
details can differ from what we are
familiar with and the differences can be
small temperature differences in one
part of space versus another or they can
be far more significant even the the
particles that make up that other realm
may be different from the particles that
make up our realm their masses can be
different their charges can be different
their fundamental physical features can
be different so out there in that wider
cosmological landscape it can be the
wild wild west of realities and they
don't have to worry about proton
deterioration there may be realms in
which they don't have to worry about
protons falling apart the wild the
really crazy idea is that if you're very
careful mathematically and analyzing
these theories you realize that there
have to be realms out there that
duplicate ours as well many can be
different but there have to be versions
of this reality that are also
instantiating
curr out there and you know they're
realms so you come to these crazy
sounding sci-fi sounding ideas that you
and I are having this conversation out
there in other distant realms an
infinite number of traps infinite number
of times and moreover small differences
can also arise in these other realms
where maybe our positions are
interchanged at the table or you know
maybe your name is a you know Joe Greene
and I'm Brian Rogan or there's like
strange realities that can be taking
place and this is not an overworked
theorists imagination this is the
careful dispassionate analysis of the
mathematical equations now I should say
there are some physicists who see this
implication and say whoa you guys have
fallen off the deep end your theory has
imploded because any theory that
predicts that kind of a wealth of
realities that are kind of untestable
because they're so far away that we will
never interact with them that's the kind
of theory that we have been trained to
avoid to excise hmm however the more you
know forward thinking I'd like to
describe us physicists say hey math has
proven to be a very valuable guide over
the course of hundreds of years and if
this is where the math is taking us it's
at least worthy of our attention to
investigate it fully and possibly come
to the conclusion that this is how
reality actually behaves Jesus that's
the weirdest one the weirdest one it's
like when people talk about intelligent
life somewhere in the universe that
you're out there or the inversion of you
or infinite versions of you yeah and it
can um be disturbing like what do you
mean by you right if there are many of
yous out there each of whom has an equal
claim on being you because they've had
the same experiences and they have the
same memories and maybe you've made
infinite very variations in the
decisions that you've made through your
life that's right so you could meet a
Brian Greene your age somewhere out
there in the universe that's made the
right choices
exactly become a gambling addict yeah
you know it's like a star trek episode
where you've got we've got like Spock
and evil spa
now the one that had the little beard on
right so there's gonna be a little beard
version of me a goatee out there yeah so
yeah you know yeah and and thing I want
to stress is this sounds kooky yeah and
the danger of kooky sounding ideas and
physics is that they're people who then
jump offer it and say well if that's
possible then then this is possible
maybe I can with my mind you know effect
what other people are so there's all
sorts of crazy ideas that can be
inspired by the weird insights of modern
physics and you've really got to keep
straight what's real and what's
ridiculous if that's a problem right
when people start using especially if
they're articulate they start using
scientific lingo to describe things that
are very unscientific sort of like what
the bleep yeah but that was one of those
movies where a lot of people like there
was all this quantum talk and yeah dr.
quantum was in it a little cartoon you
know particles and waves and like
there's science behind this but then at
the end of it really it was something
that was created by someone who runs a
cult yeah who believes they're
channeling someone who's like a
thousand-year-old alien like that that
whole ramp thing yeah but let me tell
you if you have a moment please
so a couple years ago I was a middle of
a big project in fact I describe this
and toward the end of the book so you'll
you'll get to this little anecdote if
you choose to carry on reading I was in
the middle of a big project and a
speaking opportunity came in and I
didn't properly vet it you know the
money look good and looked like a fine
thing and I signed off on it and then a
few days before I'm going I realized
it's to go to talk to Judy zebra Knight
who channels ratha thirty-five thousand
year old the Marion sage and I said to
you know the folks who should have been
checking in on this like the lecture
agent I can't go and they're like hey
Bryan it's tomorrow it's too late to
back out you know I was like Jesus
Christ you know so I look at some videos
online and I see her on like the Merv
Griffin Show where you know she she
channels Ramtha
on live television I know what year this
was you know she snaps her head forward
it goes
she changes her voice it becomes like
something between the Queen and Yoda you
know great weird plays though you know
hello peeing and she's talking to Merv
Griffin you know he's talking about like
an air punch goes what does airplane you
know it's not that kind of thing anyway
so I go you know and I show up and the
first thing I see is there all these
people walking around a grassy field
with their arms out like this and I'm
like like can they see your and I get
closer they're all blindfolded and I'm
saying that what what is going on here
and they described that each person has
a card around their neck where they've
written down their life's dream and an
exact copy of that card has been put out
on this big field and they have to feel
their way toward the matching card and
if they succeed this shows that this
goal or desire is gonna come to pass oh
boy you know and I'm saying to these
guys like so how's it going he goes like
really good you know one person found
their card you know in the last few
minutes like you know the odds of
probability of that happening you're
kind of not unreasonable but that's all
that this is and then they take me to
the blindfolded archers oh geez yeah you
know so they're taking bow and arrow and
they're firing at these targets and like
men I'm like standing way back on this
kind of thing and they ask me you know
do you want to try it and I was like you
know there's a photographer that's come
along I'm like no I'll avoid that and
then they introduced me to this woman
who is able to predict the next card in
a shuffled deck and you know so she'd
pull out this card and she'd say okay
it's gonna be seven of clubs and it's
like a three of spades and then the next
one is a seven of diamonds because oh
well there's the seven that I was
talking about you know one card before
you know so is this crazy circumstance
where and then I go I go to give my talk
okay because that's why I was there
after all this was just like the
preamble they were showing me what they
do I walk into this barn and III across
the threshold a barn and they all give
me a standing ovation and I'm like okay
I appreciate it but like why are you
giving me a standing ovation and I go
and I start to give my talk and I and I
say to them straight out
what I've seen here is nuts okay you
know I say you know if you're gonna try
to predict next cards in the deck you
know one average four times you'll get
the suit whenever 13 times they get the
rank there's nothing in there but the
pure probabilistic laws of mathematics
you know they rise up and give me a
standing ovation and I say it's
appreciated but why are you applauding
I'm telling you that you're wasting your
time and they applaud me again and I'm
like this is like so totally weird but
then I go to the book signing I finished
my talk in the book signing these people
they conferred mean they they talk to us
off they say there's a lot of crazy
stuff that's happening in this place but
we come here because we feel that
there's something else in the world and
we want to be around like-minded
individuals that are searching for the
deeper truth so thank you for calling
out the silliness that's happening here
but we'll come here anyway and spend our
money because we want to be part of the
journey and I have to tell you I had a
degree of sympathy for them because I
get the motivation I mean as a physicist
what we do is we are revealing strange
features of the world so I get the urge
I get the desire that the problem is
that the methodology that's being
employed is something that will never
take you closer to the truth however
much you may feel that you're among
like-minded individuals so I get the
motivation I get this sensation I get
the urge
but it's tragic that these individuals
feel that this kind of an undertaking is
a pathway that will take them toward the
deeper truth and let me just finish up
so um after this they take me to the
dinner and the dinners in a mansion at
the top of the hill and that's where
we're Judy I'm probably gonna get suit
for this conversation but really yeah I
don't know you know but but I've never
Spence yeah you're 12 you know they're
they're quite litigious aren't ya no
they definitely are you know so so
anyway there's just a one person's
opinion you know they take me to the
mansion at the top of the hill and
that's where she is
she doesn't come down and actually
participate in the talk she's like
watching it on closed-circuit television
up in the mansion
and I walk in and she hugs me but it was
too goddamn long of a hug you know I'm
saying it was like and she was like
thank you it was like this big emotional
thing and I was like I I don't I don't
get it but I think that's the way that
she brings people in to the fold and
gets them to spend the big bucks to
enter on this so-called journey toward
truth where she's you know channeling
this you know made-up fictitious sage
that somehow people buy into this is
this all still going on it was just a
couple years ago so I imagine it is
I'm imagine if she's really channeling
it and we're just missing that's right
that's certainly right every rule of
reality of physics that I understand
will not be less weird than the Big Bang
itself you know no I tell you what I
tell you why see when it comes to the
Big Bang I can sit down with the
mathematics that I understand well and I
can follow the deductive chain of
reasoning that gets us to some of these
strange implications that we're talking
about multiple big bangs of the
realities and so forth when it comes to
channeling a thirty five thousand year
old sage I don't know what the hell that
even means I don't understand the
physical processes by which that could
possibly happen I don't understand how
there could have been a being of the
sort that she's channeling alive thirty
five thousand years ago because it
doesn't have any agreement with the
archaeological record hmm you know so
there's there's a vital distinction
between weirdness that emerges from
careful mathematical analysis and
weirdness that emerges from an
overworked imagination that possibly
sees a business model whereby a lot of
money can be brought in if you can get
people to buy into your vision of how
the world works well it's sort of like
what they do is they they curate ideas
and then they run them through their
sort of filter of woowoo yeah right
exactly and then they distribute it in a
very palatable way that attracts people
that movie yeah I tell story I've told
this before so I apologize to people who
heard it there was a friend of mine at
the Comedy Store had a fur
and that I don't know her name but she
came to the comedy store and she was so
happy and I'm like she was like I'm so
happy why he's so happy she goes because
I found the secret and now that I know
about the secret I am going to be
married I am going to be this I'm going
to I'm going to have this fulfilled life
I'm going to reach my dreams and I'm
really excited about that so you know at
the time I had just seen the movie and
then I was just starting to understand
the criticism of the movie I was reading
all these you know healthcare where
scientists were breaking down all the
things that were wrong and and I know I
didn't - her dreams I just was like wow
okay and then I saw a year later outside
of another one of my shows a different
comedy club and I said hey how you doing
just like things are just not going the
way I thought I thought because of the
secret that everything would be great
but my dad is still a pain in the ass
and you know and that he always moved in
with me doesn't have any money and I
think I can't establish a good
relationship but I don't have the job
that I wanted I don't understand because
I've been using the secret I think about
it every day right and I said here's my
take on this if you talk to someone
who's very successful and you say to
them hey how did you get very successful
and they say I thought about it all the
time I have a vision board I took that
photo of the house that I wanted I put
it in the vision board that became my
house I took you know this this idea I
want a beautiful wife I want a family I
want sports cars and this and that and
now I have those things because the mind
is a powerful tool and the mind can
create reality the you're just talking
to someone who is successful how many
people thought like that and nothing
happened right
I bet Millions yeah I bet there's so
many but you're you have a that you have
a bias in successful users your those
are the ones you're talking to and just
because of the fact that they've been
able to have his extraordinarily
successful successful lives while
visualizing these things does not mean
that visualizing these things creates
yeah an extraordinarily successful life
you have to think and you have to act
and you have to do right in this trial
and error and there's a lot of lessons
to be learned but if you wanted to
simplify it at the end
once you're successful and boil it down
to a philosophy that you could sell a
course on yeah sure that's what it would
be yeah that's exactly right look
there's nothing wrong with visualizing
success but that is not the causal
ingredient right that will yield the
success and the thing that comes to mind
is you know I don't know if they do it
any longer but there was certainly a
time when Olympic athletes would be
taught to visualize say jumping over
that high ball you know and they'd run
through the whole thing but that's not
all that they were doing right they were
doing you know 10 hours a day of
training that integrated this
visualization as part of the training
program yeah you know so so so it's kind
of tragic when people buy into these
these crazy ideas and I have to tell you
when they were making that film they
called me to be in it and I think was
the director one of the producers I was
on the phone with and you know they were
describing what they were doing and I
probed sufficiently hard and some of my
friends did not probe sufficiently
hardened were in the film and regretted
it yeah but but i probe sufficiently
hard and I've said look what you're
doing to me sounds really dangerous it
sounds like a really bad thing to be
doing and they took offense in that call
back then a year after the film came out
it was either the director producer I
can't remember the gentleman's name
called me up and said I want to
apologize to you you were absolutely
right
I have finally realized what a bad film
this was to be involved in and I
completely regret it
so that I don't think is the point of
view of of you know the romp the school
of enlightenment which is behind this or
at least part of what was behind this
but at least the director or the
producer ever was saw the light and
realized that this is not the kind of
information that you want to put out in
the world because it can change people's
lives in a very negative way you know I
think your comparison to Olympic
athletes is is very good because the
Olympic athletes are visualizing
something that they already do you know
but there's a great benefit in
visualizing for athletics for martial
arts for a lot of different things
visualizing success visual
potential problems failures of your
process how you're going to adjust on
the fly all those things are great
because then when things do take place
in real-life situations you've already
prepared for them you know the path
right that right that's all about I
agree that and in fact I have to tell
you know in one of the chapters later
chapters in the book I describe theories
about why it is that we for instance
tell fictional stories I mean could
there be any evolutionary value in two
individuals telling each other a story
that they both know is false that they
know has no connection to the world
around them but yet we've been doing
that since the emergence of language and
there are these interesting evolutionary
scenarios in which what you're saying is
brought to bear in that unfamiliar
context we tell stories because it's the
minds way of rehearsing for the real
world but it's a way of rehearsing for
the real world that's completely safe so
you can go on all sorts of crazy
journeys to the underworld up into the
clouds you can engage in all sorts of
battles you can fight gods or demigods
all these things can take place within
your imagination so you're completely
safe and yet when you encounter
something that's analogous to the
stories that you've been told or retold
or embellished or told to others through
other accounts your brain is more
attuned to respond in a beneficial way
because it's not as novel as it would
have been had you not been engaged in
this fictional account of telling
stories so there's value in visualizing
there's value in telling stories but
it's not the causal part that some
individuals would want us to believe it
is yeah the only thing that I would say
contrary to that is some people develop
expectations based on fictional accounts
yeah and there's a real problem like
romantic movies where some people will
expect behavior that exists in these
romantic movies only right and it's not
indicative of human beings in the real
world yeah yeah I point well-taken I
mean I think the vital thing is that
your brain has had sufficient experience
that it can wait these fictional
accounts in a way that can enhance your
response to the world but not set undue
expectations of things that are just you
know only going to be true at a
fictional setting and not in the real
world it's just so strange to me that we
desire those I mean here are movies
right yeah like hero movies in
particular especially superhero movies
someone who possesses powers beyond
anything known to human beings or any
life-form yeah I get that yeah I mean
I'm sure you love to just snap your
fingers it fix everything but I actually
see it in a slightly different way
relevant to what we're talking about
before you know I think that the whole
hero worship that we have as a culture
mm-hmm comes again from our recognition
of how powerless we are against the
forces of nature against the inevitable
death that is facing us all and
therefore there's something deeply
seductive about the possibility of a
being that can transcend the limitations
that we mere mortals are always subject
to so I think it's built into our DNA to
respond to the way that we do them in
the manner that we do when encountering
a hero in the world I mean there's you
know you know Joseph Campbell yeah yeah
you know so you know the power of myth
but is more technical version to here
with a thousand faces you know he goes
through the the whole notion of what it
is to have a myth and it's basically an
individual it's call to action to rise
above the kinds of activities that mere
mortals will be able to undertake resist
the call at first but then Rises the
challenge goes out into the world
conquers comes back a changed individual
and shakes up the reality from which
that individual initially emerged on
this journey and there is ample evidence
that across cultures throughout the ages
we have constantly been telling these
kinds of mythological tales because they
speak to us they speak to our urge and
our desire to transcend the limitations
that our physical form and the laws of
physics
necessarily constrain us to yeah it's it
is fascinating when you think of how
many different languages and how many
different cultures share those same
archetypal themes yeah yeah and I do
think it all comes if you look way back
into the history of the ideas it comes
from this initial recognition that we
are mortal and the fact that our brains
are able to not just fix on the moment
but can think about the entire timeline
is the one that makes that a poignant
realization and if we couldn't think
about the future who would what would it
matter if we knew that we were going to
die I mean it would mean nothing right
but the fact that we can innovate and
the fact that we have ingenuity that
allows us to you know make the wheel
that allows us to build the pyramids
that allows us to come up with quantum
mechanics and Einstein's equations and
Beethoven symphony and and Picasso's
work the fact that we can undertake all
of these expressions of creative will
and the desire to transcend the world
around us has a downside and the
downside is we recognize that we are not
going to be here for very long and I
think that motivates a certain kind of
engagement with the world and hero
worship is part of it
Kurzweil is a fascinating character yeah
he thinks he's going to be around
forever yeah I was wrapping him up yeah
have you discussed any of this stuff
with him you know I don't know him
personally I have certainly gone to some
of his talks and I think he and I had
one exchange at some point in the past
and I totally get where he's coming from
you know he feels that we're perhaps the
final mortal generation and how sad it
is after you know a hundred thousand
generations of humans if we could only
stick around for one more generation
science would come to a point where we
would be immortal and that feels like a
tragic state of affairs I don't think
he's right and I think most people who
think about this deeply don't think he's
right either however many vitamins you
take and however much science is
progressing
the notion that we are just a generation
or two from immortality I think is
wishful thinking this is a strange
concept of immortality - because it's
not necessarily you it's a downloaded
version of you that will exist in some
sort of computer right which is what
does that mean right that sounds like
hell yeah it could be yeah you know
harem sleep in computers well I allow
for the possibility that that maybe it
would be a way of being in the world
that would have upsides that are hard
for us as flesh-and-blood individuals to
appreciation or at this point but it
raises the deep question would that be a
good thing in fact if you had that
opportunity to be downloaded in some
form and that would allow you to hold on
to all your memories build new memories
on top of them have experiences maybe
there's an avatar that you're able to
drive but through you know your mental
machinations is out there in the world
would you do it I might have said yes
before I've had some pretty profound
psychedelic experiences and then from
then I said I'm gonna hedge my bets let
me see what's next right let's see what
happens when the lights go out oh really
do you think there may be something that
happens when the lights go out I don't
know yeah I don't know what I mean for
sure your body is going to decay and you
are going to become a part of the earth
you're becoming part unless they cremate
you or unless they write embalm you with
some toxic chemicals then nothing can
use your your dead tissue which is
really a shame yeah it's really shame
that we do that right yeah I mean unless
he murders you and you have to exhume
you in the past assault in the future
whether to solve a murder right I I
don't know what what do you think
consciousness is I think consciousness
is clearly just a factor of brain tissue
and an energy or do you think it's
possible that what our brain is is
something that tunes into consciousness
yeah well I spend I spent some time
thinking about this question I think
it's perhaps the deepest question that
faces science or even humanity at some
level and my own personal
active is that consciousness is nothing
more than the choreographed motion of
particles in various quantum states
inside a gloppy gray structure that sits
inside this thing that we call a head do
I have any proof for that No
does anybody have any proof for what
consciousness is not at all at this
moment but the history of the
reductionist program where we've been
able to take some of the more
spectacular creations that have emerged
in the world and recognize that they are
nothing but the product of their
ingredients in the laws of physics leads
me to extrapolate that idea to the
experience of consciousness and having
said that there's a deep puzzle it's
called the hard problem of consciousness
which is if electrons and quarks and
particles and laws of physics are all
that there is and if you buy into the
fact that electrons don't have an inner
world that quarks don't have an inner
world how can it be that by taking a
collection of those particles you can
turn on the lights
how can a collection of mindless
thoughtless particles somehow yield
mindful experience and that's a deep
question that science has not yet
answered my own feeling is when we
understand the brain better that
question will evaporate we'll look at
the brain with our newfound
understanding maybe it's a hundred years
of the making maybe a thousand years in
the making and we'll say aha when
electrons and quarks and protons move in
this particular configuration one of the
byproducts is an inner sensation that we
call conscious experience and that to me
is the likely answer that we will find
but there are some very smart well
respected people who go in a very
different direction there are some who
say electrons and protons and quarks
they do have a fundamental proto
conscious quality they themselves are
conscious beings of a sort now it's not
like you're gonna have electrons that
are crying or quarks that are anguishing
but if you haven't
little proto element of conscious
experience that is imbued into a
particle and then you take a lot of the
particles and put them together the
ideas that yields the manifest conscious
experience that we're familiar with I
don't buy into that but what people I do
pick a position well I take a position
on this because I guess my view is you
look out at the world and what you do as
a physicist is you move the smallest
degree required to explain the phenomena
that you are observing and to move from
our current understanding of the world
to leapfrog to a place where electrons
are conscious and quarks are conscious
to me is such a fantastically radical
move that I don't consider it justified
to make that move with our current level
of understanding there was a time back
in the 1800s when life itself was so
mystical that people basically said the
same kind of thing how could a
collection of lifeless particles ever
come together and yield a living being
they said that they can't you have to
induce a life force you have to inject
vitality have you inject a life force
and that's what sparks the emergence of
life on lifeless particles I don't think
any serious scientist thinks that today
I think most serious scientists say yes
life is wonderful life is in some sense
miraculous but life is nothing but the
particles of nature coming together to
yield the complex molecules of DNA and
RNA the complex cellular structures the
cells come together to yield the more
complex multicellular organisms and
that's all that it takes to have
something that's alive no life force is
necessary that way of thinking about the
world has gone away and I'm my own
feeling is that that kind of progression
is gonna happen for consciousness today
it's utterly mysterious how it is that I
have this inner voice talking inside my
head how it is that I look around the
world and I can see the color red and I
can and I can experience the color red I
don't just have sensors that can call
that red I mean an iPhone can do that I
actually have an inner world
where I feel that color red where does
that come from hard to answer that
question but I think a hundred or a
thousand years from now will look back
and smile at how we in this era invested
consciousness with such mystical quality
when in the end it's nothing but
particles and the laws of physics and
that's all there is to it
well what's interesting to to me is that
as a human being my thoughts on
consciousness are very deep and profound
and the this this idea like what is this
thing but if I really break it down
objectively and animals have some sort
of a consciousness I mean including they
have instincts right they're try to get
away from danger they try to survive and
procreate and we developed something far
more complex and our ability to express
ourselves in language and in doing that
language or during that creation of that
language we developed all sorts of
bizarre concepts and we've developed all
sorts of different ways to describe
feelings and emotions and and
contemplate the future well these things
are continually getting more and more
complex if you go to single-celled
organisms work your way up to you know
early hominids and then get to human
beings you just see this ever increase
in form of complexity in in every way
yes and in the way that the things see
the world of course it makes sense that
there would be more complexity right but
we don't think about that when we think
of a parakeet we don't think of a
parakeet is being conscious but a
parakeet relatively speaking is far more
primitive than a chimpanzee which is
relatively speaking far more primitive
than a human being right and it's just
going to continue to evolve or if we
survive things will continue to improve
due to natural selection and the end of
mutation and all the other factors and
will be something that makes this today
look like primitive the way we look at
single-celled organisms or chimps or
whatever yeah I can well imagine that
because we're seeds you know small
changes in DNA at a tiny fraction of
percent
yields a radical change in what the
being that has that DNA is able to
accomplish but at the same time you you
made reference to psychedelic
experience yeah and I trust you agree
but tell me if you don't that those
psychedelic experiences were generated
by a slight change in the chemical
makeup of the particles coursing through
your brain and your body sometimes not
even a change sometimes a lot of them
the heavier ones are actually produced
by the brain right so so so to me that's
a great piece of data that speaks to the
fact that all it is is particles and
chemicals coursing through a structure
because if the mind was somehow external
to the physical makeup and the walls
describing it then how would the
injection say of some kind of foreign
substance or as you say the brain
producing some sort of substance that it
didn't ordinarily have within its makeup
why would that be able to have such
radical impact unconscious experience
the way I would look at it if I was
trying to argue against that would be
that your eyes and the organs of the
human eye are taking in light and
through that light are able to perceive
physical objects in the world that they
would not be able to do without light
yes there's it's a it's something that
allows you to see and it allows you to
take in depth perception and understand
that the human mind and particularly
these glands that produce these
psychedelic chemicals when experiencing
these chemicals it allows the brain to
experience things that might be there
all the time yes but that you cannot
perceive with normal human neuro
chemistry that needs to be enhanced or
the levels need to be changed and
shifted and what's really perplexing
about these chemicals is that these
chemicals are produced by your brain and
if you do take these like particularly
dimethyltryptamine yeah it's the most
potent of all the psychedelic chemicals
if you take that you have these insanely
profound visions right which is you know
leads to a lot of people having these
religious spiritual epiphanies have you
done anything have you done any
psychedelic experiences are you allowed
to talk about yeah I I have not not many
and I'm a complete lightweight in this
arena because I hardly drink you know I
hardly do anything that
it puts foreign substance into the body
but um yeah I was in I was in Amsterdam
I was I was there because I was give me
a lecture to the queen of Holland and I
gave the lecture my wife and I were both
there and after that was over we decided
to do a little experimenting and for
somebody like me who doesn't experiment
I made a mistake
haha because you eat it well well well
the first night we went out and we went
to one of these coffee bars and I guess
I can speak about this you know I am
it's legal yes totally legal exactly you
know I we we took there like the the
easy way in like the the the novice and
the version and it did nothing to me at
all that first night so the next night
when we went I went right to the bottom
of the list where there was something it
was in Dutch or something but it had
like machine guns you know pointed at a
brain kind of thing yeah so so I did
that version and it was the most
terrifying experience of my [ __ ] life
either but uh we were in a club we're in
a club and all of a sudden the world
changed and what started happening is my
brain started manufacturing versions of
myself that would converse with me and
convinced me that the reality that I was
experiencing was real and then that
version of me would destroy that reality
and the process would start over and
over and over
something you smoked a smoked yeah Wow
definitely smoked and again I suspect
that the impact was because my body has
no experience oh for sure you know and
and so I think that just enhanced the
the impact and you know it was
terrifying it was utterly I was in the
hotel room and I was clinging to the bed
and and I actually said to my wife tie
me up not not on any night it sounds
wrong I mean I mean time it cuz I'm like
terrified of what I'm gonna do right you
know wow you know and so instead you
know she she called the doctor and I was
like
she was like afraid this would be like
in the newspaper because I just like you
have left you to the Queen you know but
you know they're so used to Americans
getting in over their head with this
kind of experience is something that
they were completely used to so no they
did they sent up a doctor and the doctor
basically just gives you sugar and my
wife knew that this was a an extreme
circumstance room because I don't eat
any sugar but I was like he said eat is
my I was like taking the Milky Way bars
like a sheet or somehow or another sugar
or something I don't know I don't know
the chemistry behind this but but sugar
is the the antidote caffeine is supposed
to help tapping it help - yeah I guess
but it lasted eight hours even flying
home on the plane the next day all I did
as I sat on my seat and I put on the
headphones and there was a Beatles
Channel and I just like listened to
Beatles peripheral Ike for like seven
hours and I was just you know in this in
this place that I had never experienced
before now now you know for our
conversation you know this just made it
so intuitively obvious to me that my
conscious awareness is totally dependent
on time on account a few chemicals
that's all that's happening inside of
the head so in a way it was a valuable
experience it's not something that I
want to ever experience again absolutely
but it was something that helped align
my intuitive understanding of what
consciousness is with the scientific
recognition that it all relies upon the
stuff that's circulating inside of your
mind
yeah what's interesting about this these
heavy-duty psychedelic experiences
because what you took was by most
people's idea of very mild yeah
but profound psychedelic chemicals that
are also produced by your brain if you
just shift that ratio and not by too
much really you're not talking about it
even you talking about little small
doses of this stuff shift that ratio it
produces these profound visions it's
just like ayahuasca type is just an
orally active version of
dimethyltryptamine okay they've figured
out how to you know your brain print
your gut rather produces mono Amin
oxidase and it breaks down
dimethyltryptamine and so they figured
out how to combine an mao and
with the leaves of another plant that
has the dimethyltryptamine and I say but
you could take it there's synthetic
versions of it but the point is this is
something that your brain produces your
liver produces we know you we know it's
produced in the lung since the body
makes it yeah right but it's got it's in
there let me change the shift balance
and also you have these incredibly
profound visions yeah it makes you think
like what what we have now in terms of
our balance and our chemicals must be
different than what this fella must have
had yes chimpanzee thing right and and
primates before that as the human like
when you think of human evolution do you
ever stop to think what are we going to
be like a million years from now if we
do survive what have you ever done this
sort of thought experiment we say okay
if things keep going the same way right
we used to be very strong and very hairy
and we're getting you know progressively
softer as we don't need to use our
bodies as much our brains are getting
larger our heads are getting bigger do
you do that sort of thought experiment
to see what we're gonna become and not
in a systematic scientific way because
the process is so fraught with
incredible detail that I think it's hard
for anybody even experts in evolutionary
biology to really tell us anything that
will hold water that's really predictive
but on a general level yeah I mean
because I you know people often wonder
why is it that we haven't been visited
by aliens right this is a thing that
comes up whenever you're talking about
other life inside the universe of that
in a minute yeah yeah yeah but but but
the answer to that could be quite
straightforward nobody out there cares
about us because we're so ill developed
we're so young on the cosmic scene that
there's nothing interesting for them to
find here on planet earth so to me
there's a natural explanation for why
there can be stuff out of their life out
there and yet they don't hang out around
planet Earth it's just we don't hang
around an anthill to try to have a
conversation with you know what's going
on inside that particular structure I
buy that argument the least you do guys
we're interested in butterflies
butterflies are so boring we're we're
interested in moles we're we're into
you're interested in in whorls we're
interested in them for very specific
reasons alright so typically we're
interested either because we want to see
the evolutionary development that yields
this particular life form or because
there's a general curiosity about how
this object is put together if these
other beings are so far beyond us that
those kinds of taxon and attacks on
amines are no longer of any interest
then hanging around here may not hold
anything for them to make the journey
and stick around long enough for us to
notice I don't buy that again for two
reasons one because why would we assume
that they're so far beyond us that they
wouldn't be interested in these talking
monkeys with thermonuclear weapons who
dominate an entire planet yeah that
would be fascinating rent out some
planet right somewhere where people are
the politicians all lie to themselves
everyone gets video through the sky if
they fly in metal tubes that hurl over
the stove ER the oceans right it pollute
the oceans and eat all the fish like
these people are [ __ ] crazy yeah
we've got to go there and check this out
but but imagine that this civilization
the notion of lording over a planet is
like us talking about you know the ant
law during over a grain of sand so they
may be galactic as opposed to planetary
in their hegemony and the notion of some
little tiny rock orbiting some
nondescript star in the suburbs of this
completely ordinary galaxy off there on
the side may not have the kind of pole
that you imagined that it does how I
disagree we think it's interesting when
we see a chimp use a rock to open up a
nut you know we think it's interesting
that you know there's there's a an
amazing photograph of an orangutan
that's spearfishing have you ever seen
it I have seen that actually yeah yeah
right no it is he learned it from people
apparently but it's still interesting
nonetheless right but I don't think a
hundred years from now we're gonna be as
interested in these kind of qualities or
a thousand years from now or ten
thousand years from well so we assumed
that these things that come here from
another planet are more than ten
thousand years well that's because
that's that's a very good question and I
think the answer to that is we look at
the history of the cosmos until today
and it's say let's just call it our
universe to be concrete 13.8 billion
years and we look at life on planet
Earth and it you know a handful of
billions of years old so and a handful
of billions of years you can go from
some complex molecules to human beings
let's say you say it like it's not that
long it was it was it's not that long
because you know imagine that life began
a few billion years earlier in some
other system you know stars and galaxies
they were starting up you know a billion
years after the Big Bang so it could be
that life in other worlds has a
headstart on us by a few billion years
and we know what can happen in a few
billion years it can days from
single-cell to us and you can imagine
from a few billion years from now into
the future it could be radically
different so to say it's ten thousand
years ahead of us that to me would be
the unexplained coincidence how unlikely
that they started we started with them
ten thousand years in the span of
billions of years that seems unlikely it
is it doesn't seem unlikely when you're
talking about the infinite size of the
universe and this perhaps an infinite
number of Brian green show up there
talking to an infinite numbers of me
good good point good point so so you're
absolutely right
we're almost guaranteed if the spatial
expanse of the universe is influenced as
there are going to be places where it's
within ten thousand years or more but
those are going to be a very small
number compared to the places where it's
not ten thousand true or would it be an
infinite number of them well but there
are different kinds of infinity so you
mean in this space the exact scope of
the universe itself a small number
relatively speaking to where we are yes
well I would say slightly differently
I'd say look at a finite size ball in
this large space okay so everything's
finite let's get a five billion light
year all right and within that ball the
number that are differing from us by ten
thousand years would be very very small
compared to the number differing from us
by say a billion years or a couple of
billion years so this simply by the law
of numbers if we imagine that they're
random processes that are eternal now
there could be some physical principle
that per
Vence life from emerging before say four
billion years ago
hmm and if that's the case and we're not
aware of that principle then you'd be
absolutely right that we'd all be
roughly at the same starting point and
there's no reason to suspect that they
would be so far ahead of us
but I don't know of any such principle
but yeah yeah you almost have a
reductionist view of this right like you
did you so if you had a guess if you had
a hundred dollars to bet has alien life
ever observed us you would say no well
by observed you mean could they just
turn a big telescope in our direction
and gather some radio waves you know but
but yes I would take that bet because
frankly we've only been generating radio
wave for the last you know seventy years
so it's only a 70 light year ball around
us and within that small radius very
unlikely that there's been some alien
world that's examining us so it would
have to be something that would be able
to recognize our signal and visit us
right but don't we look at observable
planets and solar systems and discover
Goldilocks planets we didn't we examine
those planets from vast distances away
yes and wouldn't you assume that a
life-form that is perhaps thousands of
years more advanced than us with the
exponential increase in yes knowledge II
mean if they ever got to the point where
we are that they would see these
Goldilocks planets as well and recognize
that Earth is one of them yes however if
they are so far away they're going to be
examining earth as it was hundreds of
thousands or millions or billions of
years ago right so if you truly want
them to be examining us in the sense of
human presence on planet Earth then it's
a much more difficult proposition to
imagine that they've actually been doing
is it possible there's another way to
examine things where you're not hampered
by the speed of light oh not not not on
that I know of I mean any signal in the
world that we're aware of is restricted
by a very by the speed of travel which
is now look there's quantum entanglement
which is a strange property of the
quantum world in which distant objects
can behave as if they are one yes and in
some sense respond instantaneously to an
influence in one location
at a distant location no matter how far
apart they are but that isn't really
observing that more that's more
realizing correlations between physical
properties at widely separated locations
but I'm not aware of a means of
leveraging that to actually observe
what's happening in some distant
location even if you do have quantum
entangled particles for a long time my
operating theory on aliens was when I
see something that's interesting that
I'm gonna pay attention to it right
because it just it's too attractive and
it's a part of the thing of whether it's
ramp or any of these wonky things
there's something about woowoo stuff
whether it's psychics or Chandler's
that's really attractive to people yeah
some sort of a weird way and so is so
are aliens the idea that if we were
visited by something from another world
some far advanced space Daddy or
whatever it is that comes down here and
bright it's gonna show us the way that's
that's so attractive that it I think it
messes with your ordinary ability to
observed and to objectively analyze
what's real and what's not
yeah I totally agree with that and I
think it's an unfortunate feature of the
human mind that we tend to look outward
for weirdness that we'll inject into the
world more than the everyday that we
experience through through common
everyday encounters we want there to be
more we don't want it to be right that
were just on this rock around this
planet and we live for a while and then
we're gone we want it to be more than
that and so we imagine that there's some
answer floating out there in the cosmos
that maybe that will be brought down to
earth through our space daddy as you
refer to it and my view of that is it's
much more noble to recognize that there
is no answer floating out there in space
there's no space data that's gonna come
here and say this is what it's all about
the answer is you and I and everybody
else we manufacture our own meaning we
manufacture our own purpose and how much
better is it that we come up with the
our own meaning than having it bestowed
or forced upon us by some external
entity I
think that diminishes things I think it
grande eise's them because that's coming
ultimately from ourselves that makes a
lot of sense I think the hope is that
space daddy's gonna prevent nuclear war
and figure out how to fix the ocean yeah
sure no I mean and that I could that I
could certainly imagine happened it so
there's knowledge out there in the world
that you could imagine that that we
haven't yet encountered that we could
make use of so fantastic but the other
thing that's worth keeping in mind and
this I think is surprising to some
people you can do a calculation as to
whether consciousness can't itself
persist indefinitely in the universe you
can ask yourself sure earth may go away
you and I we're going to go away we
recognize all this but is it possible
that some kind of conscious being can
continue to cogitate indefinitely far
into the future or its progeny continue
to cogitate and you can pretty much
establish that thought itself will come
to an end in this universe thought
itself is a limited lifetime phenomenon
in the cosmos so when at least our
universe right yes so I'm gonna focus
just on our lockdown of protons when we
get to that point there's no room for
thought no that's part of it but I'm
willing to go further I'm willing to
imagine that even with the breakdown of
protons that there's some way that the
particles that it spawns electrons
neutrinos photons whatever somehow
through some configuration of
widely-separated particles is able to
have signals going back and forth that
allows this group of particles to think
I'm willing to posit that in order to be
as general as possible and with that
assumption you can still prove that the
relentless rise in entropy that we were
talking about before ensures that any
cogitating being that happens to still
be able to persist in this unusual realm
of particles will ultimately burn up in
the entropic waste generated by its own
process of thinking so the process of
thought itself in the far future will
generate too much heat for that being to
be able to release that heat to the
environment and to avoid
up in its own waste when you think you
will fry it's it's always been
interesting to me when I've really
stepped back and looked at it that our
ideas of the importance of thought are
so egocentric when we take into
consideration the the vast scope of the
universe and how majestic so much we see
in the cosmos that there's no thought at
least as far as we know whatsoever
like like hyper Nova's like like give
you know star nurseries all these
different things that we see in the
cosmos that are infinitely larger than
us and responsible for life itself yeah
that these processes create the very
elements that are needed to create life
but we're so concerned with this one
animal's ability to think and ponder
yeah create and and emotions and and
write stories and that to us it's so
egocentric how is every self-centered
when you take a universe yeah I mean we
are to finite beings sitting in the
valley yeah you know in front of a
wooden desk ya know it's really weird
they don't think about it as so
important everything does it is it is
and it's hard to not think in those
terms but uh
I encourage people the part of the point
of this book is to encourage people to
think in a cosmic way and recognize the
point that you're making
yeah which are we these little tiny tiny
finite beings crawling around on this
planet we're here for a brief moment of
cosmic time and that's all there is to
it and some will feel like oh my god
that's disturbing that's distressing my
point is hey extol celebrate the fact
that you were here for this brief I mean
think about the collection of quantum
events stretching back from the Big Bang
until today that had to turn out exactly
as they did for you and for me to
actually exist each one of these quantum
events and there are nearly infinitely
many of them could have turned out that
way instead of this yielding a universe
in which neither you nor I nor anybody
else would be here and yet against those
astounding odds astounding odds we're
here that is cause for celebration and
you can
further not only over here we can figure
out how we got here
we can create art we can write the
stories that you are referring to we can
create comedy we can build monuments we
can create films we can do things that
inanimate objects can't so this to me is
where the value and purpose and meaning
comes from as opposed to trying to look
out and hope space daddy comes with the
answer of you know flashing in neon sign
saying aha that's what it's all about
that's never gonna happen it isn't what
it might it's possible I so every time I
say it's not gonna happen I mean
unlikely that it's gonna very unlike
yeah I agree with that but it's it's
interesting to me that that's the thing
that we look forward to the most to the
average person if they thinks about they
think about space they think about
intelligent life yeah that is far more
interesting to them than the fact that
there's black holes out there that are
devouring planets yeah they're sucking
stars into its event horizon yeah yeah
this infinite point of density that we
can't even really begin to imagine with
our own little brains yeah yeah and and
the fact that all this arose without a
guiding intelligence yeah you know that
there are black holes and there are
active galactic nuclei and there are
black holes slamming into each other
creating gravitational waves that we can
actually detect I mean it is a
wonderfully rich reality that we are
fortunate to be part of do you
experience much pushback or much
[Music]
conflict from religious people who don't
like the fact that you describe things
in that way that didn't need an
intelligent force yeah intelligent
creator - it's an interesting question
because the biological community people
like Richard Dawkins and the like I
think have really borne the brunt of the
religious pushback because they're
dealing directly with phenomena of life
and that's the precious commodity that
somehow we want to be sacred and
therefore our religious sensibility will
push back on it just being the mindless
laws of physics and evolution yielding
you know life on planet Earth they
haven't pushed as hard
on the quantum physicists and the
cosmologists as they have on the
biologists but I have had conversations
many of them are respectful as opposed
to antagonistic where the view is that I
am wrongheaded that I am missing the
point and some of these religious folks
are fantastically accomplished
scientists that's weird
yeah I mean I went to a gathering I
think I can talk about now his
closed-door gathering you weren't meant
to describe you too but yeah it was
right I'm really open myself up and and
I thought it was it was cyant was called
science in the spiritual quest and it
was a bunch of scientists that were
being brought together and I thought it
was going to be an interesting but
ultimately OneNote meeting I thought
everybody's gonna basically say the same
thing there could be a god there's no
evidence for a god we've got the laws of
physics and we're gonna just press
forward under the assumption that
physics is all there is until the clouds
part and God reveals him or herself or
itself to us and at that point we may
change our tune it was not one note I
was the only person who had that
perspective in the room everybody else
was coming out religion from a very
different way of thinking about the
world in fact there's one Nobel laureate
in the room who got up and sang Psalms
as part of his presentation and I was
sitting there and I was like what is
happening here this is so unexpected to
me and what it really meant was I was so
close-minded into the varieties of
religious engagement that happened in
the world and it opened my eyes and
there's one noble Lord in particular I
did say to him at the end I said when
you look at me and you hear my view what
do you think and he kind of put his arm
around me in an avuncular what and said
you know you're you're a real smart guy
and you don't understand the true
reality and I think ultimately you will
because you're open-minded and you're on
a journey and I hope that your journey
will finally take you to the place where
I have been for for many years that was
so unexpected mm-hmm that does Nobel
laureate who I respected for his his
concrete mathematical and experimental
work saw the world
completely differently now was a bactrim
of belief yeah absolutely no absolutely
but I was the one who was far round one
I was the one who were untethered yeah I
mean I came in there I was like whoa you
know and and and and and and clearly
they arranged the meeting to have a
spectrum of perspectives I mean this is
not something that was randomly designed
and it just so happened but it was an
eye opener now and from that I went to
read you know William James's book a
varieties of religious experience
no maybe yeah so it's a book that
William James great psychologist wrote
in 1902
and it was based on a series of lectures
I think he gave in Scotland and it is
the most heartfelt and rational approach
to religion and science that I think has
ever been written and yet most people
don't know much about it
because what he does is he goes through
and he documents through his own
research and through reading biographies
and interviewing individuals the vastly
different ways that people think about
religion and why they think about
religion and the value that religion has
in their lives and and and when you read
that book it doesn't convert me I
haven't changed my views on whether or
not there is a God but it has changed my
views on the value of a religious
sensibility the role that it plays in
people's lives now look it can be you
know you talk to people like sam harris
and and and you know it's it's a
destructive force in the world and it
has been a destructive force in some
ways but that's not the full story a
fuller story is that for some
individuals it gives a connection to a
historical lineage that's deeply valued
for some individuals it puts their life
in a larger setting that allows them to
be in the world in a more productive way
so there are a whole range of roles that
religious engagement can play the
problem is when you start to pit it
against scientific insight then you run
into trouble but religion was never
developed to give us factual information
about the world religion will never give
us the electron magnetic moment to nine
decimal places that's the purview of
scientific investigation
and if you can keep these straight in
your mind there's a definite and
powerful role for a religious
sensibility in the world yeah I feel
like it gives people in a lot of ways of
scaffolding for ethics and morality and
allows them some alleviation of anxiety
yeah exactly a feeling of purpose is but
like you said as long as it's not
conflicting with rigid scientific
reality yeah like right scientific
provable scientific reality yeah and I
gotta tell you this if anything you know
Richard Dawkins had him on the program
so you know that his his MO in the world
is very anti religious I think he would
agree with me on that I don't want to
put words into his mouth but I did a
event with him in New York The Beacon
Theater I don't know it's maybe a year
ago or something like that and it was
very interesting because in a one-on-one
conversation his views were very similar
to mine
look we don't agree with in totality but
I was saying to him there are times I go
around the world and I will do things
that are other ly irrational I'll knock
on wood for good luck
I'll speak to my dead father I know that
he's not really there I'll pray to God
on occasion if I think that I could use
that backup not because I think there's
some bearded individual in the sky it's
just a behavioural tendency that I find
to be comforting and useful and I said
this to Richard and he said I totally
got it I was like what he was like I
totally get he said he said in fact he
said I don't like to sleep in a house
that has a reputation as being haunted
you know you know and and for me it was
such a beautiful human moment it was
such a beautiful human moment where we
were just like being human beings right
and and he said and he only said we're
both sinners and I agree we are both
sinners in that sense because we know
how the world works we know this doesn't
make any sense and yes it's still part
of somehow how we behave in the world
and I think there's a value to
recognizing that that is what it means
to be human you will engage in the world
in ways that are not necessarily
strictly adhering to some rational
perspective of how the scientific world
I would love to see Richard Dawkins
outside of a haunted house not going you
know yeah so so you know um it's all
just to say yeah that I kind of feel
like there are many pathways toward
insight in the world there are many ways
to live a life there are many ways to
come to terms with our own impermanence
and it's not as though something is
right or something is wrong it's a
question of is it useful to you and I
think that we have to be very open
minded in the kinds of behaviors that
that we allow to happen in the world you
know you know even romp it it's nutty
stuff you know but if some of those
individuals who go there find that it
allows them to live in the world in a
more productive way alleviating anxiety
feeling like they're on a spiritual
quest hmm so be it yeah that's the thing
that's something I mean it's hard for
people to understand if you're not in
that space that headspace it there you
don't need this structure but for some
people even Scientology or something
along those lines it seems loopy on
paper can provide them yeah legitimate
structure and and benefit their lives
yeah in a tangible ways they could
describe to you yeah exactly and my
feeling is that if there was and I don't
know this to be the case maybe some
biologists will push back on this but if
there was a race of for want of a better
word you know Vulcan like individuals
who approached the world in a completely
rational manner evaluating the data
figuring out the most sensible course of
action competing against a crazy group
of individuals like us who will come up
with wild fictional ideas gods in the
heavens
you know demons haunting the world I
think it's the latter group that
ultimately would triumph because with
that kind of freedom of thought you get
novelty you get ingenuity you get
creativity and so I feel as though this
is part and parcel of who we are and why
we have
survived and to sort of come at the
world with a scientific club that's
meant to smash away anything that
disagrees with the scientific worldview
is an unfortunate way of looking at the
world yeah there's something about
creativity that it doesn't necessarily
have to abide by any laws of logic and
it can still be beneficial yeah and and
and and and that's why it's so stunning
right when somebody comes up with
something it's like where did that come
from it didn't come from a rational
approach to working out you know Brahms
third symphony it emerged from the
churning emotions of an individual who
happens to be made up of trillions of
particles guided by physical law
responding to the environment which is
impinging his senses with an incredible
array of influences and through that
world emerges the spectacular piece of
music hmm that's breathtaking yeah
utterly breathtaking yeah and it's
amazing what that music can inspire yeah
as it reaches out to you know X amount
of people and then causes different
thoughts in their mind yeah and then
that causes in turn another branch of
creativity another yeah new line of
thinking that they might have never
never pursued but yeah and that to me
establishes that the notion that
language is the only way that we can
know about the world Vic and Stein had
this perspective not the limits of my
language limits of my world that seems
to me uh turley wrong I mean the
experience of music or the experience of
cogitating about the world but not
trying to overlay a narrative upon it
just feeling your way in to reality
reveals things about the world that I
think are are beyond linguistic do you
ever listen to music when you're you're
pondering an equation or whether you're
going over a problem it's an interesting
question when I was in college I
couldn't have any sound on when I was
trying to say learn quantum mechanics or
relativity I would find that it would
capture my brain to fully and I couldn't
focus on the equations that I was trying
to understand but the funny thing is in
writing this book for the very first
time I found that there were passages
that I couldn't write if it was quiet I
needed to have music playing because in
some sense by focusing too directly on
what I was trying to say I couldn't say
it hmm I only found that I could make
progress in certain kinds of
descriptions by allowing my brain to fly
off through whatever musical experience
I was playing and allowing the freedom
of thought to then emerge within that
unusual for me environment what kind of
music well it varied incredibly a lot of
slayer no but uh so some of it was
classical I remember there's one vital
of passage I was writing words do you
know pentatonix the they are a
spectacular acapella group who are able
to take songs that you have heard and
transform them into sort of transcendent
performances so you should check these
guys out
but other times you know it would just
be loud rock
lud beatles loud Rolling Stones the
soundtrack from the greatest showman
you know just blaring that thing and and
somehow it just allowed me a certain
kind of linguistic freedom that I could
not acquire in my normal way of being in
the world which is everyone's quiet let
me just work out my equations and I need
total focus and no distraction so is
this something that you sort of evolved
over the course of your career
absolutely absolutely it was not there
early on and you know there's this
phenomenon I don't know if this is
anything more than a metaphor or an
analogy but whatever you know there's
certain things in the night sky that you
can't see if you look at them directly
but by looking off axis you're able to
invoke other qualities of the eye that
are able to sense those features of the
night sky and I kind of feel like it's
the same thing sometimes by focusing
directly on what you want to do you
can't do it and you've got to look Oh
bleep you got a
off-axis metaphorically and that's the
only way that you can accomplish what
you set out to do and certainly music is
one of the ways to take one's attention
and shift it in a different direction to
get that oblique view of what it is that
you're trying to do and I have found
that it allows for progress that
otherwise is unattainable and is that
the case also when you were writing this
book it absolutely was a case right in
this book you know there you know
I have a very a wife is very
understanding so we have a house ups and
we live in Manhattan you know I'm at
Columbia but she would let me go up to
our house upstate with the dogs and by
myself and I would disappear for weeks
on end and I'd hold myself up in this
cabin in the woods and I would sometimes
write deep into the night and there were
no neighbors around so I could turn on
the music at whatever volume I found
useful and I would do it and I would
find you know that it freed up a certain
kind of creative thought process that to
me was striking because I had never
approached work in that way before and
it was really deeply interesting so how
did you come to this idea of doing it
that way of I I was struggling on
certain things and I felt as though I am
approaching this in a very flat-footed
way I want it right about this you know
say what about right about human
creativity or want to write about
religious engagement and I am just doing
what I've always done which is I have
this equation and I want to solve it
so I'm going to bring the tools of
mathematics to bear to solve it and I
was approaching this writing project in
exactly the same mind frame and as it
wasn't working I said let me smack my
brain around a little bit and and so one
way of you know it could be psychedelics
I didn't go that direction but I smacked
it around by forcing myself to be
subject to a great deal of distraction
in the environment around me and it
really made a difference it's
interesting that you did it in a
calculated manner yes yes yes oh sorry I
can't break free Foley from
my physicist training you know but it's
wise I mean that that way of doing it is
well and it's also a time-tested you
know from right from Thoreau to you know
yeah and the funny thing is you never
worked for me in the past because the
focus I think when I'm doing mathematics
it does need at least for me personally
to be that kind of non distracted total
focus on what's going on as a right
writer it's a very romantic notion to
you have to go to the woods and a cabin
that's what's up right that's what
everybody wants to do Yeah right right
exactly you know and I'm missing is
whisky I'm supposed to get drunk out
there like I said I are hardly ever
drink you know but um it was an unusual
creative experience which to me opened
up a different way of going about trying
to create things in the world as you
write more and more books you find it to
be more more difficult or do you find it
to be easier well my early books were
all focused on trying to bring
scientific ideas out to the general
public now the elegant universe was
about string theory that but the cosmos
space and time hidden realities about
multiple universes and so in that role
I'm basically trying to translate from
the cutting-edge research into ordinary
human language so that people who don't
want to go to graduate school can get
the basic idea of what's going on in
this book is a very different
proposition i I feel like I've moved in
a significantly different direction
through this book because yes there's
science you know entropy evolution the
history of the universe from the
beginning to the end but the focus on
why we humans do what we do why we tell
stories the emergence of language why we
tell myths why we engage in religious
experience why creative expression is so
important to us this felt like it was
drawing upon things I've been thinking
about for decades but never put into to
writing so it was a harder exercise than
anything that I did before because it
was a different exercise but in the end
one that I felt was even more gratifying
because it was making clear why these
ideas matter as opposed to just trying
to tickle the brain of the reader I'm
trying to actually if you will touch the
heart and soul of the reader and
something which if it's successful feels
very gratifying I would imagine that
would be very hard to end to feel how
like to put the cover on it and to go
that's it yeah right it is and I thought
that's true almost with with all books
you know the the famous adage is that
you never finish a book you abandon them
you know that that's all that ever
happens and that was true in spades in
this particular case because the subject
was so big you know and you can always
imagine going further in this direction
or enhancing that description but at
some point you recognize that you know
life is an ongoing process and a book is
ultimately a snapshot of where the
author was at the moment that the book
was written and that to me is really
what happens here this is a snapshot of
my view of the human condition set
against the cosmological unfolding and
how much of your perceptions of these
things has evolved you know as an
educator and as a scientist and as a
person who's in the public eye how much
how much of your perceptions on these
ideas have changed over the course of
your career huge huge I think I was a
very hard-nosed science thinker when I
started I think part of this may have
been I became a professor at a
relatively young age I think it was 27
when I got my first faculty job so many
of the graduate students were the same
age as me so I think I felt the need to
have a very rigid scientific outlook on
the world peak because of that and you
know as I've gotten older that has
changed and my willingness to entertain
a broader range of thought and
experience and ways of being has
absolutely grown the other thing that's
had a vast and vital impact on me our
students you know for 30 years the only
thing I really taught was technical
physics courses quantum mechanics or
relativity
you know thermodynamics and what do you
do there you're at the blackboard you're
putting equations up there you're trying
to get the kids to be able to solve
problems and understand what the
mathematics is all about so the only
thing you're really ever doing is
touching the cognitive part of their
brain for the last few years I've been
of course the students didn't know it
that's actually based on this book so I
wanted to try out the ideas with young
minds so I taught a course at Columbia
Laura jhin's and meaning and in that
course I had students from across the
campus not just the physics students at
the neuro students the anthropology
students the linguistic students the
theological orange yeah so there's a
whole range of students and to see how
their understanding of how their major
or subject fits in to the cosmological
unfolding changed many of their
perspectives on what it is that they're
studying and what they're doing and to
have students come to my office and to
feel shooken up shaking up whatever the
right form of that verb is where they're
saying you know I've lived my life in
such a way but now I'm gonna think about
religion as perhaps an evolutionarily
interesting and useful development as
opposed to something from on high or
when I think about creative expression
as something that might seed ingenuity
and innovation as opposed to something
that is just pure inspiration coming
from the outer world I'm thinking about
my life differently and some of them
frankly would be upset I've had students
come in tears and I'd never had that
when I teach quantum mechanics you know
yeah more than one more than one because
they'd say this course is kind of
shaking my sense of who I am and what I
am in the world what was the key aspect
of it that was shaking them well for
some students it was the it was the
notion of religion mm-hmm because many
of them or at least some of them had a
traditional religious upbringing and
their academic life and their religious
life were completely separate and now
when you have a course in which you're
focusing upon how it would be that this
institution of religion might naturally
evolve on planet earth based upon what
we know about humans and human brains
and the evolutionary pressures that
we've been under some of them began to
think about religion as a very different
proposition than the one that they had
when they were growing up and I was in a
position that I'd never been before of
basically counseling of student and
saying hey it's okay to have your world
shake a little mint it's okay to think
about these
you may come back to exactly where you
were before this course but if a
collection of ideas can make you rethink
your life at least it'll cast it in a
different light it illuminated
differently go with it see what happens
and I never had a conversation like that
one teaching Schrodinger's equation you
know and for me is the most gratifying
pedagogical experiences that I've ever
had because you're reaching the whole
person as opposed to just reaching this
cognitive technique of solving equations
if you can talk religion with a really
intelligent person whose objective who
has a belief it's it's such an
interesting subject because it's it
requires suspension of disbelief in
order to absorb some of the stories but
there is clearly a history behind this
of thousands of years of translations
and yeah you trying to get to the what
did they mean when they wrote this down
yeah how much did they know and what
were they trying to do what they're just
trying to get everybody to calm down and
stay in line right or were they trying
to find some means of gluing the group
together by a sheriff yes or you know
their folks who basically say that there
are qualities of the human brain that
naturally leave it open to a religious
sensibilities yeah I mean for instance
we have agency detection systems in our
brain where we look around the world and
we tend to assign agency to things that
happen that's useful right because you
know if you mistake a wind blown branch
for a Jaguar yeah it's fine
you thought with Jaguar but it's just a
branch but if the reverse happens you
think it you know was a Jaguar and you
think it's a wind blown Brent you're
gonna get eaten so we tend to over endow
agency into the world there is
evolutionary value to that so when the
wind blows we tend to think there's a
mind up there when the river gurgles we
tend to think that there's a mind in
there and this is sort of the seed for
the kinds of perspectives that you find
in many of the world's religions so
there's there's natural course of events
that can lead to the arising of the
institution or at least the ideas behind
the
institution of religion and for students
that have never encountered that idea
before it can really shake things up and
I think in a very valuable way you know
so so I think are absolutely right
having a conversation with somebody who
has a religious perspective is deeply
interesting yes to understand where that
mine came to the place that it got to
and from a personal Sensibility I give
you you know I just give you one little
anecdote you know my dad died I was 23
years old and unexpectedly I've been
visiting home or I was at Harvard at the
time I was visiting from Cambridge and
we had a nice weekend and by the time I
got back to Cambridge on the bus my mom
called me said dad's dead
it was so so shocking it was like so
sudden it was so complete and I remember
I went back home and my dad was not a
religious man but we knew that he would
want to have a religious ceremony and we
and we did it and we had you know a
minyan of Jews coming to the house to
recite the Kaddish prior because we
weren't religious we didn't know what we
were doing you know and I had no idea
what these men were saying but it was
deeply comforting in fact I didn't want
to know what they were saying to me was
just a collection of ancient sounds but
this sounds connected me across the
generations to a culture that had been
extended back 5000 years and in a moment
of crisis that was a very comforting and
useful connection to have yeah that that
is where I find people get the most out
of religion in in the fact that it
brings communities together in this sort
of cohesive ritual yeah everybody acts
together and everybody you feel like
there's completion to it yeah like
you're putting someone you know yeah
putting someone into perspective and
you're doing so with this religious
ceremony and when large groups of people
get together and engage in a ritual
behavior something magical happens you
know I've spoken to evolutionary
psychologists like Steve Pinker who's a
wonderful thinker yeah okay and and you
know Steve is skeptical that
this kind of ritual behavior can yield
the kind of cohesive bonding that some
people suggest that it does but you know
you probably have but I have the on
occasion engaged in these ritual
behaviors you know mass drumming and
movements you know and I got to tell you
you are quickly I find transported to a
place where you are now part of a
collective and you feel yourself melting
into the group and you are one and if
you've never had that experience I think
it's something that you should have
because I think it's a vital part of our
heritage it is part of how we got to be
who we are
yeah there's something about group
acceptance and a group of people acting
and doing something together that does
create this very strange bond yeah it
doesn't necessarily exist amongst
individuals it's a it's a weird bond is
a very weird bond because it has nothing
to do with the individuals nothing to do
with the personality of Jim or Mary it's
it's irrelevant at that point it's
somehow joining you together into this
massive humanity that's all engaged in
the same practice and somehow you feel
as though your identity melts into the
larger whole I don't know why it happens
there's negative aspects to that sort of
course with that you know mob mentality
of course I give you ever been in a
situation where things got chaotic and
you really had this feeling like
anything can happen in a moment I've
seen it happen I've never been part of
it but alright weird but I have a
feeling in the air yeah I have an
analogous one which is you know my
brother is a Hari Krishna well you know
and so you know he is 13 years older
than me and and left college in the 60s
which was a tumultuous time and and went
to Europe and ultimately joined into
what many people think of as some kind
of cult ish activity yeah and and so but
but he's not a cult thinker he's an
original thinker he's a brilliant
thinker and yet within this group
mentality you can imagine a certain kind
of groupthink can take over at least
people imagine that this happens so yes
it has positive aspects and it can have
negative aspects but in the end I think
there is a long Lin
age in which those of our forebears who
survived were the ones who could join
together into these more potent these
more powerful groups and that way were
able to triumph over other groups you
know in the ancestral environment you
know there-there's different readings of
the archaeological record whether it was
a dangerous place in the hunter/gatherer
past or a sort of placid place but one
reading says it was a very dangerous
place and therefore those groups that
survived were the ones who were able to
establish this kind of allegiance to the
whole yes and certainly I think this
kind of ritual behavior may have been
part of that bond together through
shared experience yes yeah and belief
yeah and if you're all believing in the
same supernatural entity that's a
powerful and principled powerful glue do
you find that there's I mean I don't
want to say in arrogance in some
academics that maybe that's not the
right word but this being too quick to
dismiss any positive benefit at all
about religion yes it's the knee-jerk
reaction you know among a certain group
of academics and it feels deeply
unfortunate to me it almost feels like a
religion of its own sort when it's just
the response as opposed to a careful
thoughtful heartfelt analysis of the
situation I frankly wish that more
people would read William James's book
because I do think that it's the kind of
because here's a scientist right a
deeply thoughtful scientist who knows
how to analyze data knows how to
rationally engage with the world who was
plumbing the depths of religion in a
very very meaningful and sensitive way
you know and by the end of these
lectures though I think is lecture
number twenty or something he describes
religion as this as something that helps
the journey toward the the terror and
the beauty of phenomenon he describes it
as the the voice of the Thunder the
gentleness of the summer rain he
described it in terms of the sublimity
of the stars and this kind of
transcendent approach to the religious
experience I think brings it out of the
academic guise that is often
thrown upon it which is something that
is contravening everything we know about
the world it's causing people to think
in ways that are irrational I mean this
whole trope that you hear it's not that
there isn't some truth to that but it's
an incomplete truth and if you're
willing to approach religion in a way
where you discard the pieces that offend
you throw away the parts that you think
are utter nonsense only keep those
aspects that are useful to you in your
life
then there is a place for it I think
therein lies the problem with a lot of
people they're not willing to do that
right so this need for suspension of
disbelief troubles them so much that
they feel like fools if they buy into
something right and we're also dealing
with all religions except the ones that
are super questionable like Scientology
or Mormonism right that are very old and
the idea of maybe it would be better if
we came up with something that we could
all agree on in 2020 right maybe it
would be wonderful if we have something
that maybe has science in it maybe
something that has our a genuine
understanding of how human beings react
and what what the benefits of community
yeah and having these in environments
were loving conscious people communicate
with each other in a very positive way
that this could be a new form of this
thing that we seem to desire so greatly
yeah and I agree and I have to say I
make this point in the book because the
point that I make there is that to truly
engage with the world you have to use a
variety of stories we're fundamentally
storytellers that's what human beings
are now there's the reductionist story
that physicists are well-equipped to
talk about with particles and laws of
physics on top of that you've got the
chemists story the complex molecules you
got the biologists story that begins to
talk about cells in life you got the
psychological story the
neurophysiological story that brings a
mind in consciousness and within that
you then have all of the activities that
conscious beings undertake which
includes religion and includes telling
other kinds of stories and includes
creative expression you need them all
and to sort of say that the scientific
account is the only account by which
you're ever going to gain true qualities
of the
is a very in my view limited description
of what truth is there is objective
truth in the world that we can measure
that we can describe the equations of so
forth but there's also internal truth
spiritual truth that you get to by
self-examination it's real in the sense
that you are understanding how you
respond to the world and that is
something which is deeply personal but
utterly real and whether it's through
psychedelics whether it's through
ayahuasca whether it's through a
spiritual journey whether it's through
religion regardless all of this adds
color to the story of what it means to
be a human being do you spend any time
meditating I do I'm not particularly
effective at it and so most people are
that way yeah you know but you know
years ago defective ones well years ago
a friend of mine bought me one of these
transcendental meditation courses and I
was like okay I'll just try it he BC he
spent the money I'm gonna actually go
and do it and it was kind of eye-opening
there was a lot of what you might call
woo woo stuff that was happening in the
lectures and in fact the funny thing is
the guy giving the lecture he did
recognize me and you could I could tell
how uncomfortable he was giving his
normal description because he kept
looking at me sheepishly as he invoked
quantum physics and things of that you
know but I was I told my dude you know
whatever this I'm not here to judge you
I'm just here to sort of see what's
going on but the idea of allowing the
mind to be in a different mode of
operation which is sort of how I
summarized the experience you know if
you're if you're reciting the mantra in
your mind and allowing that to be a sort
of pedal point a driver of how your mind
is behaving at that moment that's a very
different way of being in the world from
thinking about grocery shopping or
solving Einstein's equations and I think
that to me is the the value of it it's a
systematic way to put your mind in a
different mode of operation and at times
I find it very useful to move into that
place hmm-what when when you started
doing transdermal meditation what about
it was
weird well what was weird with number
one was doing this in this in this group
setting which is how you start on this
course and moreover it being framed in a
manner that I had trouble aligning with
my understanding of how the world works
by virtue of the lectures that were
given to us for what it is what we were
doing but through the practice I sort of
found I'm sure I'm just translating from
what they were saying in the lecture
into a language that I'm more
comfortable with and that made it less
weird for me because like what you were
talking about religion just kind of
cutting out the thing cutting on the
thing that didn't make any sense to me
and saying hey what is this really about
what this really is about is breaking
the usual chain of thought that is 99.9%
of the time of how I live in the world
and allowing my brain to have a chain of
thought that is artificial because I'm
sitting here forcing myself to recite
this mantra inside my mind but that's a
very useful way of being because it's
unfamiliar and it's novel and it allows
my brain to operate in a different way
so when I translated it into that
language it all of a sudden made a lot
more sense to me and became not weird at
all
it became an interesting practice and do
you still do it I do it when I feel I
need it so either friends of mine who
say I cannot live in the world if I
don't do my 20 minutes in the morning
simply you know that that's part of my
routine I don't feel that way but there
are moments when I say whoa I need to do
it and based on circumstance based on
what's happening in a given moment it
allows a kind of mental reset if if
that's a language that makes sense and
that reset I consider to be a valuable
thing to do now should you do you do do
you do this I do I don't do TM yeah but
I do meditate and a regular basis yeah a
regular basis and I also have a float
tank yeah oh you don't use really like a
deprivation yeah yeah in this building
yeah that's whatever they I'll show it
to you after we're done Wow
yeah all right can I do it sure you
could you I have you done I've never
done it before I I find it a little bit
terrifying you haven't say I do yeah
there's plenty of them there's a bunch
of different flow place
not terrifying at all really yeah you
just float relax and but it's complete
darkness oh yeah yes because I have the
little I have some claustrophobia
yeah and that's like for instance I
can't go into an MRI machine oh really
yeah yeah totally I'm smart why why
don't you get that out of your head I
tried I gotta tell you I trained so I
have a desk in my office where it's only
about like one foot high and I'd slide
my body underneath the desk clock the
door could look too weird and I'd stay
under there as long as I possibly could
how long myself like 15 20 the minute
but I get into the real machine and
really yeah my wife's mom was like that
yeah like she did an MRI and she's like
it was the worst experience of my wife
I'm like I did two of them last week I
thoughtlessly
I totally understand her I don't really
yeah I don't understand why someone as
smart as you would not recognize well
there's just sitting around me and I do
I do but it's it's like the irrational
part of being I get in there my heart
starts to pound when I think that comes
from I don't know it because it wasn't
always there and in it and it has gotten
worse in certains there was a time again
it's gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna come
across like a nutcase it was that trip
to Amsterdam now there's actually times
when I couldn't even go in a tunnel in a
car the claudia was that bad really
yeah I was in a taxicab I had to go to
New Jersey you know in Manhattan so I
had to take a Lincoln Tunnel and as the
taxis approached in the tunnel I said to
the guy I can't do it I can't do it and
the guy says boy I can't let you out
it's illegal to let you out I said you
got to let me out I can't do it and I
just opened the door and it got out oh
my god that's so crazy but now I'm fine
with tunnels so I don't I don't know
what it is that that maybe you're to
smaller senshu ated it there may be you
to say yeah and maybe you're a is
playing tricks with you and giving you
anxiety to sort of shake it up the world
and yeah maybe your maybe currently
contemplating the gigantic picture yeah
actual scope of the universe and yeah
but now I'm pretty stable about these
things so it's just a mirage machine so
it's really close into you but you gotta
just do a lot of MRIs you know exactly
I'm sure that would do it that would
absolutely do probably right if you have
MRIs on a regular basis and I'm sure you
get used to it but yeah I just I just do
a real simple type of meditation when I
probably
we eventually gonna take a TM course cuz
my friend Tom Papa he's really into TM
and he raves about it yeah but I just
sit down and I breathe I just
concentrate only on my breath and I and
it comes and goes but I concentrate only
on my breath and I find really good
relief from that yoga is the same thing
I do yoga I try to do it at least twice
a week
when I know you yeah that there's a lot
of benefit in that in the same way in
that it's so difficult and in the poses
if you can only concentrate on your
breath just balance and concentrate on
your breath you'll be filled with
activity enough with the with things to
concentrate on with the balancing of the
posture and then the breath that it acts
as a almost brain scouring it cleanses
the mind of unnecessary anxiety and a
lot of other just by even doing that for
a long time yes sir I know yoga's been
I've been pretty steady for the last
four years right right
and my wife does a lot of yoga she keeps
telling me that I need to do it it's
great you know it's great it's great for
the body as well and I think the more
comfortable your body is the better your
at least for me better my mind got a
little doubt that you know last for the
last you've been doing peloton bike you
know but then I herniated a disc in my
man and for last two months I've
basically been unable to move so how did
you do that well you know I I think it
was throwing out the Christmas tree oh
you know Mandy Andy and you know my 92
year old mother has used this
opportunity to say because we're Jewish
guys we weren't allowed to have a
Christmas tree going up yeah this is
this is this is meaningful right here
you know you know but my my Christian
wife is all too happy that that I'm
flexible on that count for sure what is
going on with your back now yeah well
it's it's bad it's bad
did you get an MRI I did get MRI one
thing sort of see it yeah so I'm just
pushing it's the nerves pushing against
a nerve yeah have you heard of something
called regeni keen do you know what no I
don't regeni keen is something that I
used for a bulging disc and it's
incredibly beneficial it's it was
created by a doctor in Germany and it
was illegal
States until a few years back they move
the process of here it's not covered by
insurance but it's very very beneficial
for that and what they do is it's
essentially a more advanced version of
platelet-rich plasma
so they take your blood out they do this
process it takes about 12 hours and then
they react this serum they take the
serum out of the blood looks like this
yellow serum and they inject it directly
into the areas and it's a right into the
spine right into the area where the
spine is bulging so although and it
allows it to relax it's the most potent
anti-inflammation drug that they can
they can use it's like instead of
cortisone which is talking about exactly
what's cortisone can help you as well
guineas provide temporary relief but
what this does is actually heals the
area really yeah it's very beneficial I
had a real bad bulging disc in my neck
that was making my hands go numb so my
toes are numb yeah yeah yeah but they
can give you relief and it's in Santa
Monica there's a place called lifespan
medicine I'll connect you to the I'm so
curious about what I just said friend of
mine there he had a real problem with
his neck within two weeks it was better
he got hit by a car when he was on his
motorcycle my friend in Del Rey and he
was really [ __ ] up his his back was so
bad that like we were at the comic store
and I'm like people came near me he
tensed up but what's Mady goes dude my
neck is so messed up so many bumps into
me I'm in sharp pain yeah and I'm like
real and then he started describing to
me so I said I've got the thing for you
and I said him to place Regina Kane is
amazing I've had it done several to
genican I gotta check it yeah I've had
it done on my lower but well a lot of
like athletes like Peyton Manning and
I'll Kobe Bryant they've they flew to
Germany to get this procedure done
because it's exactly yea legal there
including the UFC president Dana White
which is where I found out about it and
then I found out that they were opening
offices in America and Dallas they have
one they have one in Santa Monica and I
think somewhere else maybe New York
maybe maybe yeah but it's an amazing
procedure I mean it really is super
beneficial particularly for that kind of
in here because it's been it's been
tough for instance I can't sleep because
there's no position yeah yeah now the
value of that is I have done so much
reading over the last two months because
I'm like up half the night and I only
out when it's like utter utter
exhaustion but hey you spinal
decompression have you ever done any of
that I did I went to this physical
therapy place where they put me up on
pulleys uh-huh and it kind of pulled the
feet
I guess away from the Mack it wasn't
like being stretched fully but your own
weight was causing the the vertebrae to
separate
did that help huge relief yeah you can
get a small inversion table yeah
thinking about that yeah well I can have
one out here you could yeah right here
there's another thing called the reverse
hyper machine and the reverse hyper
machine was created by this he's a very
famous power lifter named Lois Simmons
and Lois had this idea he's a very
brilliant guy and he had this idea that
they were trying to fuse his discs he
had a balding death right he said well a
disc is compressed like how do you get
it to decompress and he developed this
machine that strengthens the back when
you lift up the legs but then in the
lowering of the legs and actively it
provides active decompression and it
alleviated his problem dude you wear
this I'll show it to you afterwards it's
a machine yeah that you get but we are
we are physical beings right now we have
a mind that can sort of the edge of the
cosmos man but you got a bulging disc it
doesn't matter
oh yeah pain is real I mean you have to
deal with it and you have to be really
careful and for me what's really
critical is physical maintenance and I'm
very dedicated to physical maintenance
even if there's nothing wrong so called
building the core yeah there's a lot of
chin ups sit ups a lot of lower back
exercises hyper like back extensions
anything to keep things strong squats
making sure that the the more tissue you
have the more strength you have in that
tissue around particularly protecting
your joints and your spine the healthier
you're going to be yes now it's
absolutely vital because the last few
months have been hell I have to say I'll
show you listen we've already talked for
two and a half hours so I'll take you
back I'll show you yeah Brian thank you
very much for being here I really
appreciate your work and and tell people
your book one more times the title until
the end of time today it's out today a
mind matter in our search for meaning in
an evolving universe yeah well thank you
for being here make it my pleasure bye
everybody
yeah I'd love to thank you
[Music]